Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 23.
Mit dem Thema Verschwörungstheorien, die sich am Ende als wahr herausgestellt haben. Wir schränken das so ein bisschen ein.
Ja, wird sicherlich alle vollständig überrascht sein davon, dass wir die Folge 23 dazu benutzen, heute mal über Verschwörungstheorien zu reden. Aber wir dachten, diese Gelegenheit können wir nicht wirklich verstreichen lassen. Und wir wollen mal ein bisschen damit anfangen, darüber zu reden, was sind eigentlich Verschwörungstheorien? Wo kommen die her? Welche Rolle spielen sie? Und dann wollen wir ein bisschen später noch darüber reden, welche Verschwörungstheorien sich am Ende als wahr herausgestellt haben und wie man vielleicht erkennen kann, welche Theorien oder Geschichten, die ja einstmals als Verschwörungstheorien klassifiziert wurden, sich später vielleicht noch als wahr herausstellen könnten.
Wir müssen damit anfangen zu erklären, was denn eigentlich eine Verschwörungstheorie ist und wie sie sich von anderen Theorien unterscheidet. Genau, wir haben uns gedacht, wir gucken mal zurück zum Chaos Communication Congress 2007. Da gab es nämlich einen bahnbrechenden Vortrag, ich darf das sagen, von Frank und Ron zum Thema die Wahrheit und das, was wirklich passiert ist.
Ja, und zwar gingen wir davon aus, von diesem Spruch, dass jede Geschichte vier Seiten hat, deine Seite, ihre Seite, die Wahrheit und das, was wirklich passiert ist. Und ein weiteres Konzept, was wir da eingeführt haben, ist der sogenannte Major Consensus Narrative. Die Idee kommt nicht von uns, sondern die hat sich Bruce Stirling in seinem Buch Zeitgeist, das ist eines der sehr empfehlenswerten Bücher von Bruce Stirling, mal ein bisschen ausgewalzt. Und die Idee da ist folgende. Jede Geschichte, die wir so erzählt bekommen darüber, was in der Welt so passiert oder wer was kontrolliert oder warum irgendwas passiert, ist ja immer nur eine Reflektion, ein Bericht. Irgendjemand erzählt eine Geschichte darüber, sei es nun die Medien oder jemand, der dir davon erzählt. Und die Frage ist ja, wie nah ist das, was man da erzählt bekommt, eigentlich an dem dran, was wirklich passiert ist. Und jeder, der solche Geschichten erzählt, also auch die Medien, haben natürlich eigene Interessen. Und die Leute, die davon betroffen sind, haben eigene Interessen. Deswegen gibt es halt immer deine Seite, ihre Seite. Und am Ende kommt was dabei raus, was wir irgendwie als die Wahrheit empfinden, also das, was so allgemein akzeptiert ist. Und also die Abkürzung dafür ist, also man kann halt sagen, die Wahrheit ist das, was in der Wikipedia steht, weil das ist dann tatsächlich das, was der so genannte Major Consens Narrative ist. Also die Geschichte, die wir alle akzeptieren oder die ein Großteil der Leute akzeptiert und auf die man sich so geeinigt hat als so kollektives Weltbild.
Und was in den Geschichtsbüchern steht, würde man vielleicht früher sagen.
Ja, was zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt in den Geschichtsbüchern steht und dieser Major Consens Narrative ist natürlich Veränderung unterworfen. Der ist halt niemals starr und statisch, sondern der verändert sich halt je nachdem, wie viel man weiß. Und wir wollen heute mal ein bisschen darüber reden, wie solche Veränderungen passiert sind. Also wie zum Beispiel sogenannte Verschwörungstheorien dann plötzlich zur Wahrheit wurden und wie viel das möglicherweise damit zu tun hat, was wirklich passiert ist. Und wie sich so ein Major Consensus Narrative ändert und formt. Und woran man einfach auch erkennen kann, wenn Leute versuchen, sowas bewusst zu manipulieren.
Ja, wir haben uns hingesetzt und haben uns überlegt, wie kann man eine Verschwörungstheorie begreifen und was für Phasen teilt sich das auf, woraus besteht so eine Verschwörungstheorie. Und die erste Phase ist, man hört sie irgendwo, man ist auf dem Markt oder bei seinen Freunden im Internet, hört irgendwas und denkt sich, was ist das denn für eine krude Geschichte und glaubt erst mal gar nichts. Aber es gibt halt Zweifel daran, so könnte das vielleicht stimmen. Die nächste Phase ist, was ich denke.
Moment, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen drauf eingehen. Und zwar genau dieser Punkt, wo man so denkt, das passt eigentlich nicht zu meinem Weltbild. Das passt nicht zu dem, was ich sonst so denke, über die Welt zu wissen. Oder wo man sich so überlegt, so naja, könnte ja in körnlichen Wahrheit dran sein, aber ist bestimmt total übertrieben.
Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Kollision mit dem Major Consensus Narrative.
Genau.
Also man hört irgendwas, es gibt einen Konflikt und der muss jetzt irgendwie beseitigt werden.
Typischerweise ist sowas dann eben auch gerne mal von den Medien, also von den Massenmedien, als Verschwörungstheorie bezeichnet. Also wenn so langsam so dieser Effekt eintritt, nämlich dass die nächste Phase passiert, dass die Medien anfangen, darüber zu reden, dann in der Regel halt eben in der Form einer so genannten Verschwörungstheorie, auf die dann Spiegel online eine Weile so rumklopft. Also Peak Oil war zum Beispiel so ein Ding. Also Peak Oil war so der Klassiker, der halt so anfing, als so irgendwie in irgendwelchen wilden Blogs irgendwo und da hinten in irgendwelchen Büchern, die irgendwo im Selbstfallach erschienen sind und wo niemand so richtig erstmal dran glauben wollte und man dachte so naja, das würden sie uns doch erzählen, wenn jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich demnächstes Öl bald irgendwie weniger wird. Das ist doch so ein großes Ding, da wüssten doch sicherlich ein paar Leute davon.
Man sollte vielleicht auch sagen, woher diese Verschwörung herkommt, weil das ist irgendwie aus dem deutschen Sprachraum nicht völlig klar. Dieses Konzept der Verschwörung, das haben wir eigentlich nicht so, das gibt es bei uns nur in Romanen. Aber in Amerika, da gibt es Conspiracy ganz häufig als Straftatbestand. Also bei uns gibt es halt immer irgendwas Böses tun oder Anleitung, irgendwas Böses zu tun. Und diese Anleitung, das gibt es in Amerika so nicht, dafür gibt es Conspiracy. Also das heißt, man sagt, wenn sozusagen jemand raubt eine Bank aus und der Fahrer des Fluchtwagens, den will man auch irgendwie belangen können. Und das ist dann immer Conspiracy. Das heißt, diese Idee einer Conspiracy-Theory, die entsteht dadurch, dass Leute versuchen, die Schuld von sich wegzudrängen und auf andere zu lenken. Da kommt dieses Wort her, Conspiracy-Theory. Das ist eigentlich, wenn jemand vor Gericht steht als Angeklagter und dann irgendwelche wilden Theorien erzählt, dass er eigentlich unschuldig ist und diese ganzen anderen Leute waren das alle. Daher, im Deutschen ist es so ein bisschen sperrig, weil Verschwörungen gibt es bei uns eigentlich nicht außer im Roman, oder?
Ja gut, allerdings ist das Wort Verschwörungstheorie schon relativ gut eingeführt. Und das ist gut eingeführt.
Aber es ist negativ belegt bei uns, nicht wahr? Also stark negativ.
In Amiland allerdings auch. Also im englischen Sprachraum ist es auch nicht unbedingt irgendwie eine positive Assoziation damit verbunden. Naja, also jedenfalls diese Verschwörungstheorie als Geschichte, die mit dem Major Consensus Narrative kollidiert, also die halt nicht unbedingt in das reinpasst, was die Leute erwarten, hat auch eine Menge damit zu tun, dass der Major Consensus Narrative definiert, welche Geschichten erzählt werden können. Also welche Geschichten können wahr sein, weil sie mit dem Rest dessen, was wir wissen, zusammenpassen oder weil sie halt irgendwie so dermaßen von Fakten belegt sind, dass man sie nicht länger leugnen kann.
Oder dass sie einfach zum Weltbild passen allgemein. Das können auch auf Basis von irgendwelchen Vorurteilen sein. Oder als Grundlage gar sowas wie Rassismus haben. Also wenn man irgendwie Geschichten erzählt hat früher, von wegen, was weiß ich, der, keine Ahnung, der Eingewanderte, irgendwas. Das sind ja meistens die Ausländer, die irgendwie schuld sind an allem. Der hat das geklaut, ich war das nicht. Dann ist das halt als Teil einer eher rassistischen Grundhaltung in der Gesellschaft auch erstmal glaubwürdig. Auch wenn es keine Fakten gibt, die dafür sprechen. Also der Major Consensus Narrative basiert nicht nur auf Fakten. Sondern eher darauf, was man sich geeinigt hat. Das ist diese Idee, dass wir die Wahrheit nicht im naturwissenschaftlichen Sinn sehen, wie das haben wir gemessen, das war so. Sondern dass sich die Menschen darauf geeinigt haben. Dazu gehören eben nicht nur Fakten, sondern auch so Voreingenommenheiten und so.
Wobei natürlich gerade bei Verschwörungstheorien die häufiger auch gerne mal mit solchen Verurteilen daherkommen. Dass eine Verschwörungstheorie eben solche Vorurteile auch aktiv benutzt. Nach dem Motto, ja, das wissen wir ja, dass diese Leute da drüben, die mit den langen Nasen oder den spitzen Ohren, die sind diejenigen, die sowieso schon immer schuld an allem waren. Das sind dann eben auch Methoden, um solche Geschichten glaubwürdiger zu machen. Also halt tatsächlich Verschwörungstheorien, also die jüdische Weltverschwörung oder ähnlichen Unsinn, denen halt irgendeine Art von Glaubwürdigkeitsanstrich zu verleihen, indem man sich auf Rassentiments und Vorurteile, die schon ohnehin da sind, beruft und bezieht, um damit halt so ein bisschen aus der völligen Unglaubwürdigkeitsecke rauszukommen mit solchen Geschichten.
Wobei das oft im Gegenzug auch die Schwachstelle ist, über die man Verschwörungstheorien angreift, da kommen wir nachher noch zu. Aber der Punkt ist jedenfalls, man findet sich selbst in einer Position, in der man einen Widerspruch zwischen einer neuen Geschichte, die man hört und den alten Geschichten, die man gehört hat, feststellt. Und man muss es jetzt irgendwie klären. Die einfachste Version ist natürlich, man glaubt es einfach nicht und lebt sein Leben weiter. Aber bei Verschwörungstheorien, wenn man anfängt zuzuhören, dann gibt es so eine graduelle Bewegung in die Richtung, das klingt irgendwie unsinnig. Man fängt damit an, dass man denkt, das kann ja gar nicht wahr sein. Und der zweite Schritt ist, dass man sagt, naja, es klingt eigentlich immer noch wie Blödsinn, das müsste doch jemand, das müsste sich doch total einfach widerlegen lassen. Ja, das kann gar nicht wahr sein, weil es so viele Widersprüche hat zu meinem Weltbild. Das muss eigentlich, wenn man da genauer hinguckt, zerfällt es bestimmt von alleine.
Wobei natürlich gerade so große Verschwörungstheorien sich eben dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie ihr eigenes Weltbild mitbringen. Also dass eben zum Beispiel halt diese Ressentiments oder Vorurteile, die ja durchaus bei vielen Leuten da sind, so benutzt werden, dass es dann halt in ein großes, geschlossenes Weltbild passt und so. Die krassen Klassiker, also was weiß ich, irgendwie die Mondlandung zum Beispiel oder irgendwie, wie ist der Typ, der überall Echsen sieht, David Icke.
David Icke, ja.
Genau. Bei den Theorien ist es ja so, dass sich da halt so ein geschlossenes Weltbild eben formt. Weil immer mehr Leute denken, ja, da finden sich doch bestimmt noch Dinge, die man so dazu finden kann. Also wo dann man sagt, okay, wenn man die Verschwörungstheorie als gegebenen Fakt ansieht, dann kann man auch losgehen und einfach Fakten dazu finden, die die unterstützen und die darauf hinweisen, dass es offenbar innerhalb eines bestimmten geschlossenen Weltbildes wahr sein kann. Und deshalb eben das Interessante an diesem Major Consensus Narrative, es gibt halt eben nicht nur einen. Also es gibt halt so den Major Consensus Narrative, der irgendwie sich in der Wikipedia und der Tagesschau reflektiert. Aber daneben gibt es eben noch viele andere, die sich halt in bestimmten Gruppen aufhalten. Also zum Beispiel halt bei den Nazis, die haben halt ihren eigenen Major Consensus Narrative. Oder bei irgendwie Zeugen Jehovas zum Beispiel, die haben halt auch ihren eigenen Major Consensus Narrative. Und innerhalb dieser, sagen wir mal, Sub-Narrative sind natürlich ganz andere Geschichten möglich. Also bei den Zeugen Jehovas sind dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Wunder möglich. Oder bei wiedergeborenen Christen oder ähnlichem. Für die ist halt so ein Wunder eine völlig denkbare Angelegenheit. Also etwas, was sich in deren Weltbild vollständig problemlos erklären und vermitteln ist. Und deswegen kann man eben nicht immer nur so von diesem Tagesschau Wikipedia-Consens ausgehen, sondern muss auch, gerade im Internet hat man ja durchaus die Möglichkeit, sich damit vielen dieser Sub-Narrative auseinanderzusetzen. Da versteht man dann plötzlich, wenn man bestimmte Geschichten innerhalb solcher Seitenwelt, oder nehmen wir zum Beispiel Scientologen, das ist immer ein besonders tolles Beispiel, wenn man sich die Geschichten, die da, was weiß ich, irgendwie in den Haberbüchern drin stehen, wenn man sich die halt mal nimmt und die mal so unvoreingenommen liest, dann kratzt man sich echt am Kopf und fragt sich so, wie kommt man denn auf dieses schmale Brett? Was ist mit den Operating-Titans, die seit Millionen von Jahren im Weltraum rumschwirren und in die Seelen von Menschen eindringen? Dieser ganze Unsinn, der halt so klingt, ist irgendwie eine echt schlechte Star-Wars-Folge, die halt irgendwie ein bisschen zu lange ausgewalzt wurde. Star Trek-Folge, die zu lange ausgewalzt wurde. Und wenn man sich einmal auf dieses Weltbild eingelassen hat, also auf diesen Binnen-Narrativ, dann macht das plötzlich alles Sinn. Also dann ist alles plötzlich schlüssig und dann kann man auch ganz andere Geschichten daran erzählen.
Das ist die große Gefahr bei Verschwörungstheorien, dass es so einen Zirkelschluss gibt aus im Grunde lauter nicht haltbaren Details, die aber durch gegenseitige Referenzen sich gegenseitig Glaubwürdigkeit zuspielen. Und da gibt's meines Wissens auch kein eigenes Wort für, oder?
Naja, geschlossenes Weltbild ist so das deutsche Wort, ja.
Na gut, aber das sagst du auch vom Springer-Verlag.
Eben, das ist ja der interessante Punkt dabei, worüber man nicht halt im Klaren sein muss, ist, dass auch unser Major Consens-Narrative, also die Wikipedia-Tagesschau-Realität, dass die sich nicht fundamental davon unterscheidet von irgendwie, sagen wir mal, so einer Scientology-Realität, außer dadurch, dass sie halt eine wirklich große Anzahl Menschen sich darin bewegt und die als für akzeptabel und normal hält. So und deswegen eben auch dieser, der Geschichtenraum, der sich da öffnet, also die Geschichten, die man erzählen kann innerhalb dieser, dieser Realität, die sind nicht viel anders, als wenn man sich jetzt nehmen wir mal so ein Gene Roddenberry-Universum nimmt, also halt das Star Trek-Universum zum Beispiel, was ja ein in sich geschlossenes Universum ist, was irgendwie eine eigene Logik folgt und eine eigene Geschichte hat. Und die Geschichte, die wir halt tagtäglich so in den Medien vermittelt bekommen, unterscheidet sich davon nicht fundamental, sondern sie hat halt mit der Realität zu tun, indem halt immer wieder neue Geschichten darin erzählt werden und neue Fakten berichtet werden. Und sie nach und nach immer weiter aufgebaut wird. Aber am Ende ist die Frage, was sie mit dem, was wirklich passiert hat, zu tun hat, nicht immer schlüssig beantwortbar. Also nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel ein einfaches Beispiel. Jeder von euch, der mal mit Medien zu tun hatte, also insbesondere mit tagesaktuellen Reportagen zum Beispiel, und der bei einmal eigenes dabei war, was dann später in der Zeitung stand.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist total krass. Wenn man das zum ersten Mal erlebt und sich denkt, weiß, das stimmt doch gar nicht.
Dann stellt man fest, dass seine eigene Wahrnehmung dieses Ereignisses und auch die möglicherweise fast alle anderen Leute, die da waren, sich doch relativ großzügig von dem unterscheidet, was dann halt später irgendwie in der Zeitung steht oder wie im Fernsehen darüber berichtet wird. Und der Grund dafür, also man fragt sich mal so, wie kommt denn der dazu? Warum hat denn der da irgendwie so einen Unsinn erzählt? Oder wieso hat der denn ausgerechnet diesen völlig nebensächlichen Ausschnitt des eigentlichen Ereignisses genommen? Und der Grund dafür ist, dass die Medien Geschichten erzählen. Also es ist halt ihre eigentliche Kernaufgabe, dass sie Geschichten erzählen, die sich innerhalb des Major Consensus Narrative bewegen. Also innerhalb der WGP, der Tagesschau-Realität. Und dementsprechend zum Beispiel, wenn man mal einen Bericht der Junge Freiheit über ein Ereignis nimmt, also die sich in einer vollständig eigenen Parallelrealität bewegen, also ihre Nazi-News-Realitäter oder ein Bericht von PI oder so über irgend so ein Ereignis, dann wird man feststellen, dass der genauso what the fuck daneben ist, wie ein Bericht zum Beispiel der Tagesschau, nur eben angepasst an deren Universum. Das heißt also, der eigene Major Consensus Narrative, in dem man sich bewegt, trägt immer die Geschichten, die man erzählt. Und daraus resultieren halt diese merkwürdigen Differenzen zwischen dem, was wirklich passiert ist, wenn man dabei war und sich es angeguckt hat, und der Medieninterpretation, die da hinten rauskommt. Weil jeder, der zum Beispiel mal so Fernsehnews oder Reportagegeschichten mitgemacht hat, der kennt dieses Phänomen, dass die Reporter häufiger die Geschichte schon im Kopf haben. Also die wissen schon, welche Geschichte sie eigentlich erzählen wollen und brauchen dazu eigentlich nur ein paar Soundbites oder ein paar schöne Bilder dazu. Und um halt ihre Geschichte zu erzählen, die halt irgendwie rund ist, die sich halt irgendwie der typischen Elemente einer Geschichte bedient. Zum Beispiel können wir das gerade prima sehen bei den Piraten. Also die Piraten sind gerade das Postatscheibbeispiel dafür, wie so eine Geschichten erzählt werden. Zum Beispiel halt über so eine Partei und die Personen, die da drin sind. Und dass sie sich dann jetzt plötzlich zerstreiten. Und dann gibt es irgendwie eine junge Frau, die irgendwie an der Spitze der Bewegung steht. Und die ist dann aber krank und die kann nicht mehr. Das sind halt alles so Geschichten, die passen halt rein. Also das sind Geschichten, die kennt man. Die hat man schon mal gehört mit irgendwie anderen Untertönen. Und der Hammer ist...
Johanna von Orléans rettet uns alle. Ja, aber ich mein der Punkt ist, wir lachen immer, dass es alles wie eine Soap-Opera klingt. Aber das ist ja kein Zufall. Ja, sondern das ist die Einsicht, die wir gerade zu vermitteln versuchen. Soap-Opera erzählt Geschichten, die Medien erzählen auch Geschichten. Und dass es alles dieselben Geschichten sind, liegt einfach darin, dass wir so eine Sammlung an an typischen Geschichten haben, die wir eben versuchen, auf die Realität anzuwenden, wie wir sehen. Und die Medien erzählen eben genau wie die Soap-Opera in der Geschichte, nur dass die weniger doll vielleicht in den Details ausgedacht ist, wie bei so einer Soap-Opera. Aber letztendlich ist es dasselbe Muster.
Ja, und besonders schön ist, wenn man dann mal zum Beispiel anfängt, mal so griechische Tragödie zu lesen. Also das ist der eigentliche Grund, wie man heutzutage immer noch sich mal gelegentlich in den Urlaub die griechischen Tragödie ranziehen sollte. Da sind viele von diesen Geschichten schon erzählt. Also die Grundstrukturen dieser Narrative und dieser Geschichten und der Handlungsfolgen und der Motivation der handelnden Personen, die sind da schon beschrieben. Das sind halt irgendwie in völlig anderen Zusammenhängen und völlig anderen Settings. Aber die Strukturen sind die gleichen. Und das Interessante daran ist, dass offensichtlich unsere Fähigkeit neue Geschichten, Strukturen zu akzeptieren, also neue Handlungsabläufe zu akzeptieren, scheint irgendwie begrenzt zu sein. Es gibt halt durchaus eine Erweiterung dessen, also passiert immer mal wieder was Neues. Meistens, also heutzutage häufiger tatsächlich in so Fernsehserien, also zum Beispiel Firefly, da sind so ein paar Sachen drin, wo halt auch so völlig neue Story-Arcs drin sind, die halt noch nicht so erzählt wurden.
Aber das geht nur sehr graduell, also man kann da keine...
Genau, aber eben basierend auf so Archetypen und Stereotypen, die wir ja schon kennen und die uns einfach vertraut sind und wo wir einfach das Vertrauen haben, dadurch, dass die Geschichte so erzählt wird, dass wir die Struktur kennen, unbewusst, hat die Geschichte an sich ja was Vertrauenswürdiges. Also deswegen funktioniert sie.
Als Beobachtung will ich gerne sagen, wer das jetzt nicht glaubt oder ein schönes Beispiel haben will, dem empfehle ich mal eine TV-Serie, die ihr noch nicht kennt, zu gucken, aber nicht von Anfang an. Denn bei TV-Serien kann man es wunderbar sehen, wie die in der ersten Season anfangen, ihr Narrativ aufzubauen und so die Grundfesten zu legen. Und die späteren Sachen sind völlig what the fuck, wenn man irgendwie, ich muss nur Lost erwähnen oder sowas wie Fringe, mehr oder weniger neuzeitliche TV-Serien. An denen man es sehr gut sehen kann. Da fängt es also schon relativ bizarr an. Aber wenn man nicht am Anfang einsteigt, sondern irgendwo, dann sieht man sehr krass, dass man überhaupt nichts von dem versteht, was da passiert. Und gar nicht, weil das Referenzen auf andere Sachen sind, sondern weil man dieses ganze Gedankenmodell gar nicht verinnerlicht hat, auf dem das passiert. Und das ist eine Sache, die man bei sich selbst anfangen muss zu beobachten. Ja, damit man sich so ein bisschen auch verstehen kann, wenn irgendwie Dinge nicht funktionieren in der Welt. Wenn man irgendwas nicht versteht, gerade dann liegt es häufig auch daran, dass Leute mit verschiedenen Gedankenmodellen darauf zugehen. Und die einzige Art, da irgendwas gegen zu tun, ist, dass man guckt, dass man nicht immer mit denselben Leuten redet, sondern sich ein bisschen umtut auch mit anderen Leuten.
Naja, und sich auch durchaus mal auf andere Handlungs- und Geschichtenräume einlässt. Also zum Beispiel halt irgendwie sowas wie, ja, sich zum Beispiel mal halt einfach so ein Buch von Scientology nimmt und da einfach mal wild hineinblättert.
Also gar nicht mal deren offizielle Lektüre, sondern der Hubbard hat ja vor seiner Scientology-Karriere ganz normale Sci-Fi-Bücher geschrieben. Die waren rotten schlecht und man muss man auch echt gucken, dass man die überhaupt findet irgendwo. Aber der Inhalt ist sehr ähnlich. Also seine späteren religiösen Texte basieren auf ähnlichen Ideen, was er vorher in seiner Sci-Fi-Literatur verbreitet hat. Und die kann man sich mal holen und da reingucken. Und dann sieht man plötzlich Zusammenhänge, die vorher völlig unklar waren, wie es eigentlich zu irgendwelchen Dingen gekommen ist.
Ja, also was tatsächlich empfehlenswert ist, sich halt mal den nächstbesten TV-Serie Nerd aus der Umgebung zu greifen und den mal nach so typischen Handlungsmustern und Strengen zu fragen und solchen Geschichten. Diese Leute sind dann tatsächlich mitunter doch durchaus Experten darin, solche Geschichten, Strenge zu identifizieren und ja, eben auch abstrakt erzählen zu können. Ja, naja, wir wollten uns...
Wir waren eigentlich bei den Phasen noch...
Na gut, es ist halt insofern wichtig, eben auch mal die verschiedenen Varianten von Verschwörungstheorien zu erzählen. Und wir wollen uns ja heute um eine besondere Abart kümmern, nämlich die, die tatsächlich am Ende als eben nicht Verschwörungstheorien, also als irgendwie Unsinn herausstellen, sondern als die Wahrheit. Oder zumindest, ja, also dass die zur Wahrheit werden, also sich irgendwie in dem, was wirklich passiert ist, irgendwie annähern. Und dann halt am Ende doch im Major Consensus Narrative landen. Weil die sind ja durchaus interessant, wenn man die relativ frühzeitig erkennen kann, wie man dann damit umgeht oder dass man sie zumindest rechtzeitig in sein Weltbild einsortiert, dann hat man halt schon mal ein bisschen mehr Durchblick so. Und ja, typischerweise fangen die halt eben an mit dem, ja, klingt ja wie totaler Bullshit, muss ich doch einfach wieder legen lassen. Und dann fängt man halt mal nur an, eine Runde zu suchen und zu googeln.
Und die Ausreden werden immer klein. Also das Brett, auf dem man steht, um die Theorie nicht glauben zu können, wird kleiner, wenn man das beobachtet. Es geht dann, das kann gar nicht wahr sein. Dann, naja, das wird sich schon ganz einfach wieder legen lassen. Und der nächste Schritt ist, aber das müsste doch jemand gemerkt haben. Ich kann doch nicht der Erste sein, der das sieht und den Widerspruch warnen. Das ist immer so der letzte Schritt, bevor das umkippt. Und den Teil, den ich immer wieder beobachten kann und den ich sehr spannend finde, ist, dass der Übergang von, das müsste doch jemand außer mir gemerkt haben, zu, haben wir doch schon immer gewusst, das ist nämlich der letzte und finale Schritt, dass der sehr abrupt ist. Da gibt es also im Runde keinen Übergang. Und dadurch, dass diese ganzen Verschwörungstheorien ein Teil von dem Narrativ sind, mit dem wir leben, die sind zwar noch nicht der Konsens, aber man hat sich schon mal gehört. Ja, und zwar fast alle haben sich schon mal gehört. Dadurch gibt es, wenn es dann akzeptiert wird als die Wahrheit, gibt es keine Phase, wo sich alle fragen, wie konnten wir das denn jemals nicht glauben, sondern es geht eigentlich nahtlos über zu. Ja, das haben wir doch schon immer alle gewusst.
Also eben der Übergang, also mein Lieblingsbeispiel wie immer, da ist halt tatsächlich Piek-Eul. Der Übergang von irgendwelche Spinner und die können sowieso nicht belegen und das ist doch schon alles eigentlich total widerlegt, zu, da könnte ja was dran sein, passiert heutzutage immer schneller eben durchs Internet. Was eben damit zusammenhängt, dass Leute, die nach irgendwie solchen Sachen suchen, also nach Informationen dazu suchen, finden im Zweifel die Informationen, finden die Belege, können sich selber die Studien ranziehen und müssen sich halt nicht auf irgendwie obskure Dritthand-Referenzen an irgendwelchen hektografierten Blättchen wie früher verlassen. Also da ist halt durchaus ein gravierender Unterschied und man findet eben auch schneller andere Leute, um darüber mal zu diskutieren oder irgendwie abzuklopfen, ob man jetzt gerade sich in so ein David Icky-Lizard-Menschen-Universum hinabbegeben hat versehentlich oder ob denn doch möglicherweise was dran ist.
Also die zentrale Einsicht ist jedenfalls, dass die Wahrheit nicht auf tatsächlich von mir beobachtbaren Sachen basiert, sondern auf Vertrauen. Ja, am Ende, wenn ich im Internet irgendwelche Quellen klicke, den vertraue ich ja auch. Die Frage, ob etwas die Wahrheit ist, wenn nicht...
Du vertraust Sachen aus dem Internet?
Na ja, natürlich. Ja, also verständlich. Besonders wenn Blogfefe die...
Ach so, ja gut, okay, ja, ja, ja.
Aber der Punkt ist jedenfalls, ob ich, ob gesellschaftlich etwas als die Wahrheit empfunden wird oder nicht, hängt letztendlich davon ab, wie viele andere Leute um mich herum auch daran glauben. Das heißt, es ist eine soziale Sache und keine wissenschaftliche Sache. Ja, das heißt, es hängt von meiner Peergroup ab, von den Leuten um mich herum, ob ich so einer Sache glaube oder nicht. Und das kann von einem Tag auf den nächsten komplett umschwenken.
Ja, und die Frage ist halt eben, passiert sie eben nur in deiner Peergroup? Also in deinem Gruppen-Minor-Consensus-Narrative? Oder wann schwingt es halt so weit um, dass es halt eben in die Wikipedia-Tagesschau-Realität reingeht? Und das Interessante daran ist, da gibt es halt so eine Phase, die ich eigentlich persönlich am spannendsten finde, wenn es eigentlich schon alle wissen. Also wenn es eigentlich die Journalisten schon wissen und auch die Politiker wissen und so alle, die sich irgendwie so um so ein Thema kümmern, dann kann eigentlich schon alle wissen, dass es so ist. Also was ist jetzt zum Beispiel, eines dieser Dinge war zum Beispiel Wulf, also unser Bundespräsident. Da gab es halt eben auch so eine Phase, wo es am Anfang war, es war so ein Gerücht, die halt verbreitet wurden und man dachte so, naja, wie viel kann denn da so dran sein? So klingt erstmal so ein bisschen nach Verschwörungstheorie, wahrscheinlich will denn jemand abschießen. Und nach und nach verfestigte sich aber eben die Erkenntnis, dass da wohl eine Menge dran ist an den Vorwürfen gegen den Wulf. Und irgendwann war es dann so der allgemeine Konsens. Also irgendwann gab es so einen Punkt, wo man darüber nicht mehr diskutieren musste oder sich nicht mehr irgendjemand überzeugen musste, sondern es einfach quasi als vorausgesetzt ansehen konnte. Nur war dieser Punkt weit vor der publizierten Tagesschau-Wikipedia-Realität. Also weit davor, bevor es halt irgendwie in die offizielle Realität einging, gab es eben schon diesen Binnenkonsens darüber, was denn da wohl die Wahrheit gewesen ist. Und der dann eben auch unter anderem halt eben diese, ja die Medienpublikation und den Recherchedruck da auch getrieben hat.
Es gibt noch eine Sache, die aus den bisherigen Beobachtungen folgt, die ich auch sehr spannend finde. Es ist nicht mehr so, also wenn ich als Wissenschaftler mir so ein paar Papers durchlese und am Ende zu einem Schluss komme, gibt es einen definierten Punkt, zu dem ich meine Meinung ändere oder anpasse oder eine neue Idee habe. Und ab da habe ich dann diese Idee. Aber bei diesen sozialen Phänomenen ist es so, dass ich vorher schon eine Weile wusste, wie es danach aussehen würde. Aber der Punkt ist zwar auch definiert, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich meine Meinung ändere, habe ich nicht mehr das Gefühl, das habe ich jetzt gerade neu gemacht, sondern das Gefühl, ich laufe jetzt schon ein Jahr damit rum, dass ich eigentlich weiß, dass es anders ist. Das heißt, bei Peak Oil gibt es nicht den Zeitpunkt, wo ich sage, wir müssen jetzt mal was tun, sondern es gibt den Zeitpunkt, wieso haben wir die letzten 20 Jahre eigentlich nichts getan. Und auch bei Wolf war das so, dass man plötzlich sich gesagt hat, wieso ist der eigentlich ins Amt gekommen, wenn es so eine Sache gibt. Und die sind ja kursiert eine ganze Weile durchs Internet. Also man hat immer so dieses Gefühl, dass man nach der eigentlichen Sache überhaupt erst kommt. Zu dem einen, zu dem dazu kommt, seine Meinung zu ändern. Also das immer, wenn man zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man sich entscheidet, das Narrativ ist jetzt so, ist es aber eigentlich schon zu spät oder schon eine Weile so gewesen, dass man schon vorher seine Meinung hätte ändern können. Und daraus ergibt sich soziologisch auch so ein Ding, dass man Erklärungsdruck hat, wenn man plötzlich eine Handlung unternehmen will, die darauf basiert, weil man dann erklären muss, warum man das bisher noch nicht gemacht hat.
Warum man zu früh ist.
Ja, nee, also sagen wir mal, nehmen wir jetzt mal den Punkt als Beispiel.
Achso, du meinst, warum bisher noch nichts passiert ist. Ja, ja, ja.
Genau, warum ist bisher noch nichts passiert? Da muss es irgendeine Erklärung für geben. Und das ist ein Widerstand, den man dann überwinden muss, wenn man den Narrativ ändert. Hat man dadurch, dass es eben kein, ich lese jetzt dieses Paper und danach weiß ich, das war alles falsch, was ich vorher geglaubt habe. Ist es jetzt so, dass ich das ja ein Jahr vorher gehört habe und alle haben es ein Jahr vorher gehört und jetzt kann ich nicht plötzlich anfangen, irgendwie große Dinge zu unternehmen, weil ich dann erklären muss, warum ich das nicht schon vorher gemacht habe. Und dadurch geht es bei vielen von diesen Verschwörungstheorien oder auch bei Sachen wie WULF, dauert es dann plötzlich wochenlang, bis tatsächlich mal irgendjemand sich traut, Dinge zu tun, um diesen Widerspruch aufzuheben, weil man einfach mit sich selbst im Widerspruch ist. Ja wieso, wenn ich das jetzt plötzlich glaube, wieso habe ich das denn eigentlich vorher nicht geglaubt? Wieso haben wir alle nichts getan? Wieso hat keiner was gemacht? Das gibt es häufiger bei Verschwörungstheorien.
Eine interessante Aspekt dabei ist eben auch dieses, eine übermächtige Partei ist involviert. Also irgendjemand, dem man jede Schokerei zutrauen würde, ist der Urheber oder der involviert. Und gegen solche Geschichten gibt es im Major Consens Narrative eigentlich den größten Widerstand. Es ist halt so, dass die publizierte Realität nimmt in der Regel übermächtige Akteuren, die schokische Dinge tun, nicht an. Also die ist halt eine Sache, die, also wenn man sowas behauptet, ist es klar erstmal eine Verschwörungstheorie. Weil der Major Consens Narrative, der große, nimmt halt in der Regel an, dass die Checks and Balances in unserer Gesellschaft so weit funktionieren und dass halt Macht irgendwie ausbalanciert wird oder kontrolliert wird und dass der Staat da schon aufpasst oder dass die Medien aufpassen, dass schon irgendjemand was tun würde, wenn es eben eine, ja, solche Machtkonzentrationen gibt und die missbraucht wird.
Oder vielleicht geht es ja auch um den Staat als Übrigen.
Genau, oder es geht halt eben zum Beispiel um den Staat oder Geheimdienst oder sowas, die sowas tun. Und dieser, also diese spezielle Subart des Major Consens Narrative, das eben nicht angenommen wird, dass irgendwie solche Leute sowas tun, also offiziell nicht angenommen wird, gibt denen natürlich Handlungsspielraum. Und ein schönes Beispiel dafür ist die Housing Bubble und mit dem, mit dem Hypothekendesaster dahinter. Da haben erstmal alle angenommen, dass es sich dabei irgendwie um Irrtümer handelte, um Computerfehler. Da hat wohl irgendjemand sich vertan.
Jede Ausrede hat funktioniert, egal wie lahm sie war. Weil es einfach niemand glauben wollte, dass so ein großes Ding unter unserer aller Nase passiert.
Mit krimineller Energie.
Und keiner merkt es.
Und mit krimineller Energie. Ja, genau. Dieses keiner merkt es, kann eigentlich niemand wirklich behaupten. Es gibt halt dieses tolle Economist-Titelbild, das kann man sich mal rausholen, von diversen Jahren bevor die Bubble geplatzt ist. Es hieß The Houses that Saved the World. Und da ging es darum, dass die Wirtschaftskrise davor, die 2007er, glaube ich, oder 2006er Krise, dass die eben dadurch im Wesentlichen überwunden wurde, weil die Amerikaner gekauft haben wie Blöde und halt ihre Hypotheken als Geldautomaten benutzt haben. Und das Titelbild war halt irgendwie so ein typisch amerikanisches Vorordhäuschen an so einem Heißluftballon. Also schon klar Bubble, ne? Also beim Economus muss man sowieso immer mehr auf die Bilder und die Bildschriften achten, weil die dann meistens noch mehr sagen als die Texte, die auch nicht so schlecht sind. Also da kann auch niemand sagen, dass es niemand wirklich wusste, aber es wollte tatsächlich niemand sehen. Das ist irgendwie diese Sache, die dazu geführt hat, dass so eine Wirtschaftskrise eben durch Hypothekenspending einigermaßen glimpflich ablief. Dass das halt irgendwie die Saat für das nächste Desaster war. Und diese Theorie, dass die Leute da kriminell gehandelt haben, dass diese Hypothekenfirmen halt irgendwie von Kriminellen betrieben wurden. Und dass halt da Leute wie Goldman Sachs halt und so, die halt einfach keinerlei Scheukanten und wirklich hochkriminell gehandelt haben, um halt irgendwie diese Hypotheken dazu sliceen und zu repackagen und sie an irgendwie deutsche Landesbanken zu verkaufen. Dass das halt de facto Kriminalität war und dass man diesen Banken nicht zugetraut hat. Also diese Änderung des Major Consensus Narrative, die war extrem spannend.
Das liegt auch an einer anderen Sache, die ich sehr wichtig finde, nämlich dass in den meisten Fällen, wenn es um so eine Verschwörungstheorie geht, ist nicht nur der Akteur übermächtig, sondern es gibt einen zumindest moralischen Handlungsbedarf für mich als Einzelnen, wenn ich mich der neuen Realität widme. Wenn ich das glaube, dass diese Banken kriminell handeln, dann besteht für mich der Handlungsbedarf, da muss ich doch mal jetzt jemand anzeigen oder irgendwas muss ich doch jetzt tun. Und das ist auch eine psychologische Schranke, um eine neue Wahrheit zu akzeptieren.
Nicht nur jemand anzeigen, ich meine, das sind ja die Leute, die mein Geld verwalten.
Ja genau, also ich müsste mein Geld da wegziehen, wenn ich glaube, dass die alle kriminell handeln.
Den muss ich doch irgendwie vertrauen können, denkt man sich doch so, ne?
Gerade die Banken sind ja nun zentral Element unserer Wirtschaftsordnung. Ja und das ist ein großer Schritt gewesen, den wir da in den letzten Jahren beobachten konnten, dass die Leute tatsächlich anfangen, den Glauben an die Integrität der Banken zu verlieren. Also das ist jetzt gar nicht mehr so, ist ganz witzig, weil wenn so was umschwingt, dann kann man danach auch überhaupt nicht mehr verstehen, wie man das jemals anders sehen konnte. Aber vor so zehn Jahren, wenn jemand gesagt hätte, die Banken sind alle kriminell, die stehen mit einem Bein im Knast und die werden unsere Wirtschaft praktisch vernichten, da hätten die Leute alle gesagt, wie jetzt, das kann ja gar nicht sein. Also das ist ein großer Schritt, den wir da gegangen sind.
Ja und die nächste gleichartige Geschichte, also diese Denkblockade oder Geschichtenblockade, ist ja dieses Too big to fail. Also dieses, wir können die nicht gegen die Wand fahren lassen, sonst bricht irgendwie alles zusammen. Geschichte, die sie uns ja erfolgreich erzählen. Das ist halt so ein Ding, wo niemand ist in der Lage, die Wahrheit oder Unwahrheit davon objektiv nachzuvollziehen. Wir müssen die Banken retten, auch wenn dabei ganze Länder vor die Hürde gehen. Und wir müssen irgendwie Griechenland so bailouten, dass die Banken halt irgendwie ihr Geld wieder kriegen, weil sonst irgendwie bricht alles zusammen. Diese Geschichte ist ja wahrscheinlich die nächste, die fallen wird. Also die halt auf der Liste der Sachen steht, die so offensichtlich noch burscht klingen, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass sie irgendwie dieses Jahrzehnt überleben wird.
Ich glaube, es ging bei diesen Sachen auch gar nicht darum, irgendwas als Wahrheit zu behaupten, sondern es ging einfach darum, dass die Bevölkerung die neue Wahrheit gehört hat, aber sie noch nicht glauben wollte, weil eben dieser Handlungsbedarf, der für den Einzelnen existiert, eine Schwelle darstellt, die man überfinden muss, um das zu glauben. Und da reicht jede noch so blöde Ausrede, um dem Einzelnen zu helfen, nicht die neue Realität zu akzeptieren. Wenn ich denke, ich kann es jetzt glauben mit den Banken, aber dann müsste ich ja eigentlich überlegen, wie ich alternativ mein Geld verwalte. Tue ich das unter die Matratze? Also das hat ja einen Rattenschwanz von Sachen, die ich dann tun müsste. Genau, lauter Konsequenzen. Und im Grunde suche ich, wenn ich mit so einer Situation konfrontiert bin, nach Möglichkeiten, wie ich von mir selbst argumentieren kann, dass ich diesen ganzen Scheiß nicht nehme. Diese ganzen Konsequenzen, ach, ich glaub das lieber nicht. Und deswegen kommen die mit Ausreden, die egal wie dämlich die sind, sie helfen mir dabei, das nicht zu glauben. Weil ich will es ja nicht glauben, weil ich dann Dinge tun müsste, die unbequem sind, die andere Folgen haben, die negativ sind für mich. Und auf diesem Schritt nicht zu tun, helfen sie mir mit Ausreden, die blöd sind. Also ich meine, offensichtlich schwachsinnig, das mit dem Too-Big-Too-Fail. Im Grunde glaubt ja jetzt schon keiner. Aber es hilft eben den Leuten dabei, in der alten Realität zu bleiben. So kann man das verstehen.
Sich nicht aufraffen zu müssen, um in die Regierung zu stürzen.
Genau.
Also ich meine, der extremer Fall davon war ja zum Beispiel das Wissen der Deutschen um die Konzentration im Vernichtungslager, die ja, wie mittlerweile relativ gut belegt ist, ist ja diese Nach-dem-Krieg-Ausrede, dass sie es alle nicht gewusst haben und keiner hat was davon geahnt, halt völliger Unsinn gewesen. Also zumindest in der Nähe der Konzentrationslager selbst haben die Leute sehr wohl gewusst, was da passiert und haben sehr wohl irgendwie die Gefangene gesehen, die durch die Straßen getrieben wurden. Und es gab irgendwie hunderttausende von Leuten, die aktiv davon partizipiert haben, irgendwie gerobbtes jüdisches Vermögen und Gegenstände bis hin zu Möbeln und Kleidung sich anzueignen. Und die trotzdem haben hinterher alle geleugnet gesagt irgendwie, ja, ach nee, das haben wir nicht gewusst, das ist ja alles ganz schrecklich und so. Da sieht man halt mal, in welchem Scale so was funktionieren kann. Also dieses sich eben nicht dem offensichtlichen Stellen müssen, weil es bequemer ist, da irgendwie nicht hingucken zu müssen. Da gibt es auch in der Psychologie diesen schönen Begriff der kognitiven Dissonanz für, wo Menschen einfach das relativ offensichtliche oder das, was irgendwie klar ist, eben nicht als solches akzeptieren wollen und stattdessen lieber eine andere Art der Geschichte oder einen anderen Abzweig in der Storyline versuchen, für sich im Kopf zu wählen, um eben mit den Konsequenzen, nämlich dass man zum Beispiel halt irgendwie Widerstand leisten müssen und dass es halt irgendwie überhaupt nicht ging, in Deutschland, dass irgendwie solche Sachen passieren. Ja, das ging halt nicht. Da wollte man halt nicht hin. Da gab es halt keinen Weg dazu. Es war halt eben doch bequem, irgendwie davon auszugehen, dass die Juden an allem schuld sind und man deswegen leichterhand irgendwie ihr Vermögen rauben kann und sie halt irgendwie ins Gras schicken darf. Und diese Art zu denken, die ist halt nicht weg. Es ist halt nicht so, dass wir annehmen können, dass wir heutzutage dagegen immun wären.
Die Beispiele müssen wir vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner wählen, um es näher an die Hörer ranzu-
Gut, okay, aber ich wollte nur mal sozusagen das erste Beispiel- Den Apperbaum wählen, um mal zu erklären, welche Ausmaße das annehmen kann und die dann halt zum Tod von Millionen von Menschen führen, ohne dass halt 100.000 oder auch Millionen von Leuten, die davon aktiv wissen, irgendwas dagegen unternehmen.
Ja, also das Beispiel, was mich am tollsten getroffen hat, will ich sagen, an den Sachen, die einen so direkt betreffen, sind ja die Demonstranten auf Demonstrationen, die von Polizisten verprügelt werden. Weil da habe ich mir auch jahrelang gedacht, also ich fing ja gar nicht mit den Demonstranten an, sondern mit irgendwelchen Fußballfans. Und da gibt es dann natürlich auch von der anderen Seite den Versuch, das Narrativ zu ändern. Da wird dann in der Tagesschau von Hooligans gesprochen und nicht von Fußballfans. Und das gibt mir als Fernsehzuschauer eine Entschuldigung in die Hand, warum ich mich da nicht auseinandersetzen muss, warum ich weiter glauben kann, dass die Polizei schon das Richtige tun wird.
Sind doch die alles Nazis, die einfach nur auf die Fresse brauchen?
Ja, also die Ausreden, die man sich selbst verstellen kann, die sind ja unbegrenzt. Aber die Tagesschau hilft eben, wenn sie dann sagt, das sind hier gewalttätige Fußballfans. Und das ist ja auch ein Zirkelschluss in unserem Narrativ. Die sind ja deswegen gewalttätig, weil sie auf der Polizeiliste sind. Und die Polizei hat sie auf die Liste getan, weil es mal eine Auseinandersetzung mit der Polizei gab, von der wir ja auch im Grunde nur das Wort der einen Seite, nämlich der Polizei, haben, dass die Leute da gewalttätig waren. Also das ist auch ein Zirkelschluss in unserem Narrativ. Aber das nehmen wir gerne hin, weil wir das Narrativ einmal akzeptiert haben. Ja, und die Idee, dass Polizisten vielleicht, ohne dass sie einen Grund dafür haben, Demonstranten verprügeln, das fing auch so an wie, ach, das kann gar nicht sein. Die Polizei ist ja dazu da, um die Leute zu beschützen.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass du einigermaßen entsetzt warst, als irgendwie diese Geschichte mit diesem Fahrradfahrer kam und dir überhaupt nicht so klar war, dass sowas durchaus irgendwie alter ist und irgendwie einigermaßen häufig passiert.
Nein, das merkt man ja auch erst, wenn man wirklich mal selbst vor Ort ist. Und ich war schockiert, als ich dieses Video gesehen hab. Das war ja auch wirklich hochauflösend. Da gab es ja keine Fragen mehr. Normalerweise vorher die Videos, die es gab, die waren ja alle irgendwie so pixelbrei und das hätte jetzt so und so interpretiert werden können. Und man denkt sich ja auch immer, wenn der dir dieses Video gibt, selber irgendwie so aus so einer Ecke kommt, dann wird er schon irgendwie das so selektiert haben, dass es schlecht aussieht und so. Aber wenn man mal anfängt, nach so einer Sache, nach solchen Sachen zu suchen, dann häufen sich die Geschichten in den Medien, dass bei der es gab irgendwie irgendwelche Vorkommnisse und dann fehlt genau die eine Minute, wo der Typ verprügelt wurde bei den Videoaufzeichnungen der Polizei und die Kamera hat immer weggeguckt. Und also wenn man mal anfängt, die Idee zu akzeptieren, dass es vielleicht, dass da was dran sein könnte, dann häufen sich auch plötzlich die Beweise dafür. Ja, und dann sind wir schon bei Schritt zwei und dann der nächste Schritt, bei Schritt drei, aus unserer Phasen-Aufkleidung oben war, dass ich sage, ja, das kann ja nicht sein, dass ich der Einzige bin, dem das jetzt auffällt, der sich diese Frage stellt. Und dann geht man im Internet in irgendwelche Foren oder in die Blog-Szene und stellt fest, ich bin auch gar nicht der Einzelne. Und irgendwann denkt man dann, na gut, dann akzeptiere ich das jetzt eben als die Wahrheit, dass es eben was passiert, dass Leute verprügelt werden. Und das ist eine Sache. Andere Sachen, die gar nicht mal mit Gewalt zu tun haben, ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, Kosmetiktests an Tierversuchen und so. Das ist ja auch eine Sache, wo dieselben Schemata greifen. Dass man sich sagt, ja, ach na ja, das kann ich jetzt vielleicht noch ignorieren. Oder man denkt sich eben, na ja, eigentlich müsste ich da jetzt anfangen, meine Einkäufe umzustellen. Und dann guckt man sich an, na ja, die, wo ich mir sicher sein kann, dass keine Tierversuche gab, die kosten aber mehr. Und dann gibt es wieder diese Schranke und dann suche ich nach Ausreden. Und dann hilft mir die Industrie mit irgendwelchen Namen Ausreden. Also die Modelle und die Sachen, die da passieren, sind sehr vergleichbar in allen möglichen Beispielen. Es geht eben von verprügelten Demonstranten über Tierversuche und natürlich auch so was wie Bio-Nahrungsmittel. Das ist ja dasselbe, dass da kommt irgendwann die Idee auf, dass die Industrie, die uns die Lebensmittel macht, vielleicht nicht unsere Gesundheit im Hinterkopf hat, sondern eher ihre Profite.
Wie sollte man auf diese Idee kommen? Also ich meine, das ist doch völlig abwegig.
Die Muster sind immer dieselben am Ende. Und wenn man mal anfängt, diese Muster so ein bisschen aktiv bei sich zu beobachten, stellt man fest, das passiert jeden Tag mit uns. Nicht nur bei Verschwörungstheorien, sondern jeden Tag, wenn wir irgendwelche Änderungen an unserem Major Consensus Narrative haben, passiert das. Und es geht natürlich manchmal um die Welt. So bei Peak Oil geht es um die Welt. Aber es geht eben auch manchmal um kleinere Sachen. Und manchmal geht es auch um Sachen, die überhaupt gar nichts direkt mit einem zu tun haben. Das finde ich immer besonders witzig. Wenn ich zum Beispiel im Internet lese, es gibt jetzt so eine Geschichte wie den Amero, das ist so eine Sache, die seit, weiß ich nicht, 10, 15 Jahren kursiert, dass die Amerikaner, also die USA, sich mit Kanada und Mexiko zusammentun und den Dollar abschaffen und stattdessen eine neue Währung namens Amero machen. Das ist so eine Theorie, wo viele Amerikaner offenbar furchtbare Angst vorhaben, was ich nicht näher verstehen kann, aber es betrifft mich als Europäer ja überhaupt nicht. Und das ist immer ganz witzig, wenn ich zu so einem Thema, was mich überhaupt nicht betrifft, versuche mir eine Meinung zu bilden oder ein Consensus Narrative zu finden. Und keine der Seiten hat irgendeinen Bezug zu meinem Leben. Da kann man ganz gut noch am ehesten genug Abstand gewinnen, um bei sich selbst die Phasen zu beobachten und sich zu fragen, warum mache ich das hier eigentlich gerade? So was ist denn das?
Und war das nur mit dem Amero?
Na bisher sieht es aus wie eine Luftnummer. Also da gibt es jetzt keine echte Beweise für. Aber es kursiert halt seit vielen Jahren.
Ist noch nicht die Wahrheit.
Ist noch nicht die Wahrheit, nein. Aber bei uns gibt es ja auch so was. Bei uns hieß es dann, es gibt eine Reserve D-Mark. Also es gibt ja bei uns wird das vorangetrieben von irgendwelchen Leuten, die einem dann Gold verkaufen wollen. Ja, die versuchen irgendwelche Geschichten im Internet zu verbreiten, dass unsere Währung kurz vor dem Zusammenbruch steht, was ja auch teilweise nicht wirklich zu leugnen ist. Da gibt es dann eben Theorien von wegen, na ja, es gibt eine Exit-Strategie der Bundesregierung, dass wir dann aus dem Euro wieder aussteigen. Und um zu zeigen, wie vorangeschritten diese Sache ist, gibt es eine Reserve D-Mark, die haben die schon auf Halde liegen und müssten sie quasi nur noch verteilen. Wann hast du das zum ersten gehört? Das gibt es auch schon viele, genau.
Na die Reserve D-Mark gibt es schon quasi mit der Euro-Einführung. Gab es diese Gerüchte schon. Auf der anderen Seite wäre ich einfach bitte enttäuscht, wenn da mal eine Bundesregierung solche Vorkehrungen nicht treffen würde. Also dann würde ich ja denken, sie baut ihr Job nicht. Also ich meine, die können auch nicht irgendwie ihr eigenes Cool-Aid irgendwie so lange trinken und daran glauben, dass es auf jeden Fall gut gehen wird.
Jedenfalls kam bei dieser Reserve-D-Markt dann, irgendwas gab es dann Fotos, von denen sich rausstellte, die waren gefotoshopt und dann kam aber raus, es gibt wirklich eine Reserve-D-Markt. Hast du das verfolgt?
Na es gab eine Reserve-D-Markt. Also es gab tatsächlich eine eine D-Markt-Reserve, die schon gedruckt war, also zu Zeiten des Kalten Krieges, und zwar für den Fall, dass der Osten anfängt, den Westen mit Blüten zu flattern, also halt Falschgeld in großen Mengen in Umlauf zu bringen. Hatten sie halt eine komplette Austauschwährung, Bargeldreserven, zumindest die Scheine rumliegen, um halt, wenn es halt zu schlimm wird, halt einfach über Nacht eine Währungsreform machen zu können. Es gibt Gerüchte, dass es sowas im Osten auch gab, da habe ich aber bisher noch keine genaueren Details zugefunden, vielleicht hat ja einer der Hörer was dazu. Und aus dieser Vorkehrung, die ja völlig, also aus der Logik des Kalten Krieges, ja völlig normal und klar ist, ist dann eben auch diese Geschichte mit der Reserve D-Mark für den Fall, dass der Euro platzt, entstanden. Und tatsächlich gibt es eine Menge Gerüchte darüber, was jetzt eigentlich passieren könnte, wenn jetzt der Euro platzt, also wie halt irgendwie dann tatsächlich die technische Durchführung eines Ausstiegsszenarios aussehen könnte. Und also aus meiner Sicht sind es durchaus Sachen, die jetzt nicht völlig unplausibel sind. Also wo ich jetzt schon sagen muss, okay, also das würde zumindest in meinen privaten Narrativ durchaus reinpassen, so dass so eine Regierung, wenn die Sache anfängt ein bisschen heikel zu werden, schon mal anfängt, ein paar Vorkehrungen zu treffen. Also ich meine, überles ich das mal, nehmen wir mal den Worstcase an und irgendwie der Euro platzt halt irgendwie zu Weihnachten. Dann, ja was machen wir denn dann? Und dann kann man nicht erst anfangen, dann irgendwie Geld zu drucken. Insofern würde ich jetzt davon ausgehen, dass es sowas gibt, aber ich würde es jetzt nicht unbedingt als Absicht eines Ausstiegsplans werten, sondern eher als eine sinnvolle Vorkehrung, die man halt einfach treffen muss.
Man muss auch sehen, dass Regierungen sowas natürlich machen sollen, ist ja deren Aufgabe. Also auch für Sachen, die völlig unplausibel sind, wie die Amerikaner haben irgendwie eine Strategie, falls die Aliens kommen, kamen neulich keine Ahnung, ob da was dran ist, aber würde ich mal von ausgehen. Ja, weil das ist ja letztendlich, dafür ist die Regierung da, für Kontinuität zu sorgen.
Der Fachbegriff dafür lautet daseinsvorsorge.
Ja. Was immer ein bisschen schwierig ist, bei solchen spekulativen Sachen bezüglich Währung und Wirtschaft, erstens, Wirtschaft ist ja nun keine, wie soll ich sagen, keine Naturwissenschaft, sondern so Geisten. Ich mach mir da grad keine Freude, glaub ich. Aber es ist ja eher eine unprinzipielle Geschichte. Das heißt, es gibt immer irgendwelche Cassandras, die den Untergang von diesem und jenem vorhersagen. Insofern ist das nicht unbedingt, will ich das jetzt nicht alles aufwerten, indem ich sage, sie haben das vorhergesehen. Es kann auch sein, dass einfach ein Crackpot war, der das schon immer gesagt hat und der das nicht wirklich vorhergesagt hat. Ja, das ist so der erste Kaviat. Der zweite ist...
Es gibt auch hinreichend viele Crackpots, dass irgendwie irgendeiner, wenn es unten...
Das wird schon recht abhängig.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch das, was irgendwie Wahrsager früher gemacht haben. Es waren halt einfach genügend und die Steuerbrandbeute ihrer Aussagen war genügend groß, dass einer von denen halt immer recht hatte. Und der hatte dann halt gerade Glück und wurde dann halt der Hofwahrsager.
Und ja, also der zweite Punkt ist, dass es da ja auch so eine schmale Linie gibt zwischen Verschwörungstheorien und Testballons. Es kommt durchaus vor, dass Regierungen anfangen und so eine Geschichte streuen, um zu gucken, wie die Bevölkerung das aufnimmt, ob das eher negativ oder eher positiv ist.
Das sind halt Tests der Grenzen des Major Consensus Narrative.
Genau, könnten wir das jetzt bringen oder würden die Leute dann durchdrehen? Ja, und das machen Regierungen durchaus gerne. Also der Schäuble hat das ja immer gern gemacht in seiner Politik, dass er irgendwelche Vorschläge gemacht hat, die so hauscharf hinter dem Reit dessen waren, was man akzeptieren wollte. Und dann hat er eben a gesehen, ob das jetzt geht oder nicht. Und b hat er aber auch die Grenzen des Denkbaren verschoben dadurch, wenn man so was anspricht. Insofern, also das ist eine valide Strategie und das muss nicht unbedingt dasselbe wie eine Verschwörungstheorie sein.
Ja, na wir können noch mal so ein bisschen zu den klassischen Verschwörungstheorien kommen.
Ja, na wir waren ja eh gerade bei der DDR mit der Reserve D-Markt.
Genau, also zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit der Wahlfälschung der DDR, also dass die Wahlen der DDR gefälscht wurden, das war halt so ein Ding, wo man genau diesen Prozess ganz prima beobachten konnte. Also wo sich halt irgendwie zuerst war das halt so ein Ding, was halt in so kleineren oppositionellen Kreisen war halt klar, die Wahlen schon gefälscht wurden, weil diese Ergebnisse sehen halt total unplausibel aus. Und das entwickelte sich dann halt relativ zügig zu so einem, eigentlich wussten alle, dass diese Wahlen gefälscht sind. Also es ist halt irgendwie, also wie jetzt genau die Mechanik aussah, war nicht so ganz klar und war auch klar, dass einfach auch eine Menge Leute in der DDR halt einfach dem Wahlvorschlag der nationalen Front zugestimmt haben. Aber eben nicht irgendwie in diesen 90-plus Kategorien, die da halt immer so rauskamen als Ergebnisse.
Ist ja letztendlich auch egal, wie es gemacht wird.
Gab es ja diese Bewegung, eben dem mal auf den Grund zu gehen und halt einfach mal sich in die Wahllokale zu stellen mit Zettel und Stift und den Auszählungen beizuwohnen und einfach mal selber zusammenzutragen und daraus halt eigene Hochrechnungen zu machen und so. Und das war dann so der Zeitpunkt, wo tatsächlich eine Menge Leute diesen Schritt gemacht haben hin zu, okay, sie verarschen uns wirklich in irgendwie gravierendem Maße und das ist tatsächlich gefälscht. Und ich kann es jetzt nicht mehr länger leugnen, weil ich halt die Beweise vor der Nase habe und irgendwie zumindest die Westmedien darüber berichtet haben.
Wobei der eigentliche Schritt ist ja in dem Moment gegeben, wo du anfängst, dich ins Wahllokal zu stellen, oder? Weil da würdest du ja nicht hingehen an der Stelle, wenn du nicht wüsstest im Grunde. Also da ging es ja nur noch um die Beweissicherung.
Ja klar, aber das war dann schon ein sehr mutiger Schritt, weil die Leute hatten natürlich auch mit Reparzeien irgendwie aller Art zu tun. Das war ja nicht so, dass es dann wie hier ist, wo man irgendwie in Hessen nur irgendwie bedroht wird mit irgendwie Anzeigen oder irgendwas, wenn man in der Wale beobachten gehen will. Sondern da war dann halt irgendwie schon, also konnte man halt einfach schon unter Vorwände in den Knast geschmissen werden und so. Also es war halt auch durchaus eher repressiv, wie dagegen vorgegangen wurde. Aber der Schritt, das am Ende klar war, selbst aus diesem relativ kleinen Sample von, ich weiß nicht, von 300 oder 400 beobachteten Wahllokalen, dass es da offenbar massive Unstimmigkeiten gab. Dass es dann mal jemand gemacht hat und sozusagen hingegangen hat, versucht hat, zumindest so etwas ähnliches wie einen Beweis zu ermitteln. Der war für viele Leute dann doch durchaus wichtig. Also Dokumentation von solchen Sachen bewirkt dann tatsächlich auch was, um eben diesen Schritt raus aus dieser Verschwörungstheorie-Ecke zu schaffen und zu sagen, okay, hier sind tatsächlich Fakten und die sehen halt irgendwie so aus, als könnten sie wirklich stimmen. Und da ist halt nicht mehr so viel drin rumzudeuteln. Das war halt schon so ein interessanter Punkt, wo man dann eben auch sieht, dass eben persönliche Aktivität durchaus dazu beitragen kann, um Geschichten, die einfach erzählt werden müssen, weil sie gesellschaftlich extrem relevant sind, auch erzählbar zu machen, indem man halt einfach dann den Geschichtenraum erweitert, indem man die Fakten auf den Tisch legt.
Aber es war wieder so ein Übergang von, also als es dann raus war, haben es eigentlich alle gewusst. Das finde ich immer den spannenden Teil an sowas. Dass es im Grunde für niemanden wirklich eine Überraschung ist, wenn der Narrativ umkippt und irgendeine Geschichte akzeptiert. Sondern dass alle Leute das schon immer gewusst haben.
Noch so ein Ding war jetzt zum Beispiel die Mafia. Also die amerikanische Mafia.
Ja, das ist vielen Leuten gar nicht bewusst. Die Idee, dass es sowas wie ein organisiertes Verbrechen gibt, dass es nicht alles verirrte Einzeltäter sind, die ist relativ neu, die ist aus den 60er Jahren. Da gab es nämlich einen Mafioso namens Joe Valerci, der bei einer Senatsanhörung das zu Protokoll gegeben hat. Und das war so hammermäßig unglaublich damals, dass die das im Radio und Fernsehen ausgestrahlt und in den Zeitungen veröffentlicht haben, was der da gesagt hat. Und danach war dann die Existenz einer organisierten kriminellen Vereinigung im Hintergrund plötzlich Teil des Narrativs. Vorher nicht.
Vorher wurde es immer als irgendwie, ja, da gibt es nicht so viel und sind einzelne Gangs und irgendwie oder für Einzeltäter oder so, ja, erzielt die Geschichte.
Was auch für die Polizei spannend ist. Denn jetzt nehmen wir mal an, die Polizei findet so ein Mord und denkt sich, das war jetzt aber glaube ich kein Einzeltäter, sondern der ist von irgendjemanden beauftragt worden. Und wenn es jetzt gar nicht Teil von dem Narrativ ist, diese Möglichkeit, dann kann die Polizei das ja auch nicht verfolgen. Also das ist durchaus mehr als nur so ein Konsens, sondern es bestimmt auch, welche Aktionen möglich sind.
Das FBI wusste es ja schon wesentlich länger, ne? Also das ist ja...
Ja, aber du musst es ja rechtfertigen als Polizeibehörde. Wenn du jetzt anfängst, irgendwelche Ermittlungen zu machen, das kannst du ja nicht ins Blaue machen. Und du kannst keine Begründung angeben, die nicht Teil von dem Narrativ ist, sondern das muss schon... Also das hat auch tatsächlich Auswirkungen.
Zumindest Teil des Binnen-Narrativs ist, ne? Also ich meine, der Narrativ in so einer Polizeibehörde unterscheidet sich ja signifikant von dem, irgendwie Major Consensus Narrative.
Ja, leider. Teilweise durchaus negativ.
Teilweise durchaus negativ. Das ist halt auch so ein interessanter Fall, ne? Also gerade bei Sicherheitsbehörden stellt sich ja halt eben dieses Müllmann-Syndrom ein, ne? Also die haben ja den ganzen Tag mit irgendwie dem Dreck und dem Scheiß, der passiert, zu tun. Und den ganzen Problemen, die irgendwie entstehen, durch alle möglichen anderen Effekte in der Gesellschaft. Und durch eine entsprechende Brille sehen sie dann eben auch alle vorgänge und alle gesellschaftlichen Handlungen, wenn eben alle aus dieser Perspektive desjenigen, der sich halt irgendwie mit den ganzen schrecklichen Seiten des Menschen und der Gesellschaft befassen muss, gesehen. Und daraus resultieren dann halt eben solche massiven Weltbilden in Kompatibilitäten, wie zum Beispiel zwischen uns und dem Zierke, der halt einfach auf seiner Vorratsdatenspeicherung besteht, weil er halt den ganzen Tag seine Einzelfallakten auf dem Tisch hat, die halt alle schrecklich sind.
Der kann sich das auch gar nicht vorstellen, dass es Leute gibt, die von der Polizei zu Unrecht verfolgt werden. Also das ist kein Akt, der spielt das nicht bei irgendwelchen Anhörungen, wenn man ihm sagt, ja aber was, wenn die Polizei das missbraucht. Das kann er sich wirklich nicht vorstellen. Und das ist echt erstaunlich, weil das konnte ich mir wiederum nicht vorstellen. Ich hab den mal getroffen irgendwann und ich dachte, der kann doch nicht wirklich so naiv sein. Aber das ist so, das passt in deren Weltbild nicht rein und damit ist es auch nicht denkbar. Und damit, wenn solche Leute gefragt werden, wie jetzt so ein Sicherheitsgesetz aussehen soll, erklärt sich auch, dass sie da so eine Klausi reinschreiben, wie wir dann vor der Nase haben und denken, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Das ist doch alles Missbrauch, Tür und Tor geöffnet. Aber Missbrauch haben die überhaupt nicht auf dem Radar, diese Leute. Sondern die sehen eben nur ihr Narrativ und da kommt das nicht vor. Und so erklärt sich das eben aus den verschiedenen Weltblicken, dass es zu solchen Gesetzen kommt.
Also was wir gerade sehen, ist ja eben, was du vorhin schon erwähntest, dieses Polizisten schlagen keine Unschuldigen. Dass es jetzt langsam anfängt zu bröckeln und zu kippen. Dass es die ersten Verurteilungen gibt und nicht immer defaultmäßig angenommen wird, dass Polizisten nicht lügen und sich nicht gegenseitig decken, sondern dass sowas überhaupt schonmal angenommen wird von Richtern, dass es überhaupt vorkommen kann, sind so die ersten Risse in diesem Narrativ, wo wieder mal eigentlich alle wissen, dass es so ist. Also dass es halt schon Fälle gibt, wo das staatliche Gewaltmonopol missbraucht wird.
Und auch danach werden es alle schon immer gewusst haben.
Genau, danach werden es halt schon wieder alle gewusst haben. Da könnt ihr euch schon mal drauf einstellen. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was kommen wird. Es gibt natürlich die Abwehrgeschichten. Es ist gerade Hammer, diese immer wieder publizierten Zahlen von wie viel mehr Polizisten im Einsatz verletzt wurden. Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar wahr. Wahrscheinlich gibt es tatsächlich mehr verletzte Polizisten, aber es gibt eben keine vergleichbare Statistik darüber, wie viele Menschen oder Unschuldige verletzt wurden oder auch wie viele Festnahmen mit übermäßiger Gewalt durchgeführt werden oder was da halt einfach die Schäden sind, die einfach durch Gewalteinsatz durch den Staat passiert. Das wird halt eben nicht betrachtet, weil das widerspricht eben dem Narrativ, dass die Polizei dein Freund und Helfer ist. Und dass es da vielleicht mal dauerliche Einzelfälle gibt oder so, aber jedenfalls keinen systematischen Machtmissbrauch gibt. Das ist halt so ein Ding, das könnte man im Auge behalten, diese Geschichte. Fefe berichtet immer gerne darüber. Das ist tatsächlich sicherlich eines der Dinge, die so in den nächsten Jahren beröselt und bröckelt werden, bis es dann plötzlich wieder alle gewusst haben.
Ja, also das ist ja auch Statistikern ein wohlbekanntes Phänomen, dass das Weltbild am Ende prägt, wie die Zahlen rezipiert werden. Also gerade bei diesen Statistiken, wie viele Polizisten Schaden davon getragen haben oder verwundet wurden, das liest sich ja, wenn man das dann in der Presse hat, liest sich das immer wie, die sind von Demonstranten angegriffen worden. Aber gelegentlich gibt es ja mal einen Pressebericht, der sich das genauer anguckt und feststellt, da zählen auch, wenn jemand im Wald umknickt, ja, ein Polizist oder wenn einer, was weiß ich, einen Hitzschlag bekommen hat, weil er zu lange in der Sonne stand. Das ist dann auch in der Statistik ein Polizist, der da ärztlich behandelt werden musste. Das heißt, es hängt wieder vom Weltbild ab, wie man das jetzt interpretiert, wenn da steht, so und so viele Polizisten mussten behandelt werden. Das heißt ja nicht, dass sie alle Opfer von Gewalt wurden.
Ja, und die Frage, wie viel damit zum Beispiel die sich aufhäufenden Überstundenzahlen damit zu tun haben, wird halt auch nicht gestellt. Also ob halt zum Beispiel die Verletzungsquoten von Polizisten einfach damit zu tun haben, dass sie halt einfach überarbeitet sind und halt unkonzentriert werden. Das ist halt einfach, also so ein, ja, wie gesagt, das ist immer eine Frage, wie man halt solche Zahlen liest. Und solange halt der Narrativ halt so ist, dass irgendwie es gibt da die bösen Demonstranten und die verklopfen arme Polizisten und gelegentlich müssen die halt auch mal irgendwie wohldosiert Gewalt anwenden, aber eigentlich...
Mit ihren Schutzwaffen.
Genau.
Verprügeln sie die Polizisten.
Solange das halt der Narrativ ist, wird sich halt an der Situation auch nichts ändern, weil es eben keinen Handlungsdruck gibt. Also keine Möglichkeit gibt, daran was zu tun.
Ja, also wir haben hier so eine Liste von Verschwörungstheorien. Manchmal fragt man sich ja, so, wer kommt denn mit sowas aus dem Wald? Hat da jemand LSD ins Wasser getan? Und es stellt sich heraus, ja, es gab auch eine Verschwörungstheorie zu LSD im Wasser. Und zwar MK Ultra ist das Stichwort dazu. Das ist eine groß angelegte Geschichte im Kalten Krieg gewesen. Da ging es darum, rauszufinden, also das fing, glaube ich, damit an, dass die Russen irgendwelche erpressten Geständnisse hatten und dass da plötzlich dann das Narrativ bei den US-Diensten war, dass die Wahrheitsdrogen hätten und dass wir auch unbedingt Wahrheitsdrogen brauchen, um das zu kontern. Und da ging dann die Forschung mit LSD los.
Also nicht nur Wahrheitsdrogen, sondern auch die Möglichkeit der Gedankenkontrolle.
Genau, da gab es die wildesten Theorien im Kalten Krieg, auch so was wie Fernenlenken von irgendwelchen, also mit Hilfe von Telepaten und Fernen. Remote-Sensing ist auch so ein Stichwort aus der Ecke. Also da gab es die wildesten Theorien. Aber es gab eben auch dieses MK-Ultra, was darin gipfelte, dass in Krankenhäusern von Experten tatsächlich Experimente an Leuten durchgeführt wurden und zwar gegen deren Willen. Das ist ein ganz übler Themenkomplex, der auch natürlich Verschwörungstheorien um sich hatte, bis dann irgendwann die Dokumente rausgekommen sind. Hast du da irgendwie die Sachen noch auf dem Radar, was da wann passiert ist, genau?
Na es gab da eine Untersuchung, das war halt die sogenannte Rockefeller-Kommission, die das untersucht hat und dann gab es halt 77 das Church-Komitee, auch einer der Meilensteine des Versuchs, irgendwie die Geheimdienste mal so ein bisschen unter Kontrolle zu bringen. Und dabei haben die dann halt auch Anhörungen gemacht mit den Opfern dieser Menschenversuche, also wo die halt einfach teilweise unwissenden oder teilweise unter falschen Angaben Leuten aus heutiger Sicht völlig unglaublich Drogencocktails verabreicht haben. Also so, wo man so denkt, es gibt da so Fälle von Leuten, die synthetische Meskalin-Derivate in Dosen gespritzt bekommen haben, dass es halt zum Kreislaufstillstand kam und so, also völlig gaga. Und da gab es ja eben auch Tests mit LSD und die halt eben, also man muss dazu wissen, halt zu den genen Drogen, wenn jemand verabreicht werden, der nicht weiß, dass er sie nimmt, dann ist das, was er da sieht und hört, ist dessen Realität. Also der kann dann nicht damit umgehen, dass er sagt, okay, ich habe jetzt eine Droge genommen, in acht Stunden ist alles wieder gut. Und nein, ich kann jetzt nicht fliegen, sondern ich lieg mich jetzt hier aufs Sofa und gucke mir irgendwie die bunten Bilder an der Decke an oder höre ein bisschen entspannte Musik, sondern der will dann tatsächlich fliegen aus dem Fenster raus, weil er denkt, das ist tatsächlich das, was er empfindet. Und da sind halt etliche Menschen umgekommen, weil sie eben unwissen Personen und exponentiere, ja, Kaninchen kann man sagen, also Menschen diese Drogen halt in Alltagssituationen verabreicht haben, also einfach in den Whisky gekippt haben oder sonst irgendwie. Also sie haben auch verschiedene Verabreichungsmethoden ausprobiert und so.
Also es waren nicht nur Drogen, sondern es ging auch darum, mit irgendwelchen speziellen Frequenzen oder sublimen so einen Frame mit irgendwelchen Botschaften einblenden. Also das Gesamtstichwort heißt Mind Control. Das Ganze ist so ein bisschen im Narrativ gelandet, weil es einen Film gab namens Manchurian Candidate. Viel später allerdings, also dieses Projekt MK Ultra, wir werden auf Wikipedia verlinken, ist ziemlich alt. Es ging schon ziemlich direkt nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg los, als nämlich die amerikanischen Dienste im Rahmen von Operation Paperclip, wo wir auch gleich noch zu kommen, weil es auch eine Verschwörungstheorie gibt, haben sie nämlich die Nazi-Wissenschaftler übernommen und die haben sich teilweise eben auch mit Folter und Brainwashing beschäftigt. Und das ist eben fortgeführt worden in der CIA. Also später dann diese LSD-Sachen kamen natürlich erst nachdem LSD gefunden wurde von den Diensten als Möglichkeit, das zu machen. So Wahrheitsdroge. Es gab eben aber auch die Frage bei MKUltra, ob man vielleicht mit irgendwelchen Frequenzen oder durch Isolierung das Bewusstsein ausschalten, verändern, fernlenken oder vielleicht so Gedächtnismanipulationen vornehmen kann. Also MKUltra war eine Riesengeschichte und das ist immer noch nicht völlig aufgedeckt, was da genau passiert ist.
Wie immer bei solchen Geschichten gibt es dann halt irgendwie Konsequenzen, die Konsequenzen haben. Also einer der Opfer dieses Programms war ein Beteiligter an diesem Programm. Frank Olsen, der starb 1953, indem er durch eine geschlossene Scheibe im zehnten oder elften Stock eines New Yorker Hotels nach draußen getreten ist. Und dann hat die CIA halt seiner Familie um den Bullshit erzählt. Und dann kam raus, dass der halt ein Bakteriologe war, der halt an biologischen Waffen geforscht hat. Und über die Menschenversuche im Rahmen von MkUltra informiert war. Also unter anderem auch über Folter-Experimente, bei denen Menschen zu Tode gefoltert wurden durch die CIA. Um halt irgendwie Erkenntnisse zu gewinnen. Und da teilweise waren auch irgendwie Nazi-Wissenschaftler daran beteiligt, die ja ihre Erkenntnisse den KZs verwendet haben im Rahmen dieses Programms. Und dann gab es halt irgendwie 1975 halt irgendwie dann diese Kommissionen und die Aufklärung dazu. Und dann haben die versucht, die mit Geld ruhig zu stellen. Interessant ist aber, dass eine ehemalige SRE-Chef, und zwar William Colby, hat dann irgendwann der Witwe von dem Oisen Dokumente gegeben, die klarmachten, dass es sich halt um den drogeninduzierten Selbstmord handelte. Also dass der halt einfach quasi mit diesen Drogen in eine Krise gestürzt wurde, die ihn zum sich umbringen brachten. Und der Hammer war dann, dass die dann versucht haben, den Colby irgendwann später nochmal vorzuladen für eine Kommission, um auszusagen, also vor das Gericht. Und dann ist der Colby mysteriös bei einem Kanu-Ausflug verstorben, bevor er da aussagen konnte. Also es hat so ein klarer Fall von Selbstmord. Also hat er halt irgendwie, normalerweise hat er bei seinen Kanu-Ausflügen halt eine Schwimmweste getragen, hat er halt nicht ungehabt. Und irgendwie sah er aus, als wenn er irgendwie hastig aufgebrochen ist aus seinem Haushalt und wurde dann halt irgendwie erst viel später irgendwo angeschwemmt. Also das sind halt so eine Geschichten, die eben genau in diese Kategorie, da gibt es halt einen übermächtigen Aktor, der halt irgendwie Sachen verbergen will passen. Und wenn man da halt so die sich die ganzen Geschichten zusammenzählt, und da gibt es ja mehrere so Geschichten, wo dann halt eine auffällige Häufung von komischen Toden und Selbstmord passiert, dann muss man halt einfach konstatieren, dass sowas offensichtlich einfach passiert. Also dass solche Sachen halt einfach üblich und möglich sind. Und interessant daran ist, dass die meisten Leute das eigentlich auch wissen, und zwar aus dem Fernsehen. Oder aus dem Kino oder aus Büchern.
Ja, genau, von irgendwelchen TV-Serien. Man kennt das ja.
Man kennt das ja, ne?
Das ist ja Teil unseres Narrativs, aber eben eher so auf der künstlerischen Ebene, nicht so auf der das passiert wirklich eben.
Genau. Und die Frage ist halt eben, warum können sie es dann halt nicht akzeptieren oder akzeptieren sie es in so einem, das passiert halt, man kann nichts dagegen tun, also wie so können solche Sachen durchgehen? Oder warum wird dann halt nicht nachgebohrt? Oder warum können halt solche Sachen wie Gladio zum Beispiel passieren, ohne dass halt irgendwie da die Leute auf die Barrikaden gehen? Und das ist halt eben so die Frage, die eben aus dem Bequemlichkeitskomponent des Narrativs resultiert. Man müsste ja dann tatsächlich Konsequenzen ziehen.
Also das darf man auch überhaupt nicht unterbewerten, die Wichtigkeit von Fiktion in Buch- oder TV-Form oder irgendwelche Filme im Kino, um das Narrativ zu erweitern. Das ist traditionell auch der Hauptgrund von Sci-Fi, wozu wir Science-Fiction brauchen. Weil man in Form von Sci-Fi eben über Sachen nachdenken kann, die sonst verboten sind. Oder Fantasy auch. Das war ja in den Sowjetunion auch so ein Ding. Die haben großartige Sci-Fi gehabt, weil sie eben die Sachen anders nicht ansprechen durften. Und das Narrativ erweitern über Geschichten, das geht auch, wenn die nicht behaupten real zu sein, die Geschichten. Es geht auch über Sci-Fi, aber dann ist eben der Effekt geringer. Auch die Geheimdienste haben das natürlich erkannt mit dem Narrativ und dass man da Einfluss nehmen kann. Und da gab es diverse Versuche, wie man nicht die Medien, also jetzt nicht direkt fernsteuern, aber doch beeinflussen kann. Eine der wichtigsten war Operation Mockingbird. Da ging es darum, dass die CIA die Medien in den 50er-Jahren versucht hat zu beeinflussen. Interessanterweise gab es auch so ein Projekt, wo es darum ging, die Kunst zu beeinflussen in Westeuropa.
Also die abstrakte Kunst.
Gerade abstrakte, moderne Kunst ist von der CIA gefördert worden, um dem Osten gegenüber demonstrieren zu können, dass wir hier Freiheit genießen im Westen. Aber es gab auch bei den Medien eben dieses Operation Mockingbird. Da ging es eben darum, den Geschichten zu geben, die sie dann beschreiben können. Und das wollten die Medien natürlich haben auch ein Interesse daran, dass diese Art von Geschichte dann nicht Teil des Narrativs wird, weil die natürlich ihre Rolle im Narrativ beibehalten möchten.
Als die des Geschichtenerzählers.
Und Wahrheitsfinder sind. Ja, und das geht natürlich nicht, dass sich da so was mit so was zu beschmutzen. Aber also das gab es auch als Verschwörungstheorie natürlich, dass die CIA sowas tut. Aber da kämpfen dann alle Beteiligten dagegen, dass das Teil des Narrativs wird. Ja, völlig klar. Und immer wenn die Medien beteiligt sind, ist es besonders schwierig, Teil von dem Narrativ zu werden, weil die eben dann eine sehr dominierende Rolle haben. Aber auch so kleinere Sachen sind durchaus Verschwörungstheorien ursprünglich. Oder man müssen jahrelang darum kämpfen, anerkannt zu werden. Jetzt Zigaretten sind ungesund zum Beispiel.
Oder Asbest ist ungesund.
Ja, oder Genfood ist ja eine Sache, wo wir noch darum kämpfen, ob das jetzt ungesund ist oder nicht. Aber wenn es dann irgendwann entschieden wird, wird wieder der Fall sein, dass alle Leute es eigentlich schon immer gewusst haben.
Oder halt jetzt gerade Pestizide und Bienen.
Ja, Pestizide und Bienen, genau, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Also jeder Imker, mit dem du redest, sagt dir halt irgendwie, es ist halt irgendwie passiert, nachdem irgendwie die Pestizide angefangen haben, irgendwie in solchen Unmengen gesprüht zu werden oder bestimmte Pestizide halt. Und halt natürlich die Varroa-Möben dazu kamen. Das heißt also, die haben es dann halt tatsächlich schon immer gewusst, aber bis es halt irgendwie in so weit im Major Consistency-Narrative ankommt, dass halt irgendwie Aktivität passiert, also dass halt diese Pestizide verboten werden zum Beispiel, da wird es halt immer noch ein bisschen brauchen. Ja.
Also es gibt auch manchmal Verschwörungstheorien, die es ins Sci-Fi-Narrativ schaffen, bevor sie es in die Realität schaffen.
Also es gab Geschichten, die man nur in Romanen erzählen kann, weil sie in der Realität noch zu krass sind.
Ja, aber die es trotzdem vorher schon als Plan gab. Also das Paradebeispiel ist Operation Northwoods. Das war ein Plan, ich glaube, aus den 60s. Da ging es eben darum, dass man die Kubaner schlecht machen wollte. Und der Plan war, ein Flugzeug zu entführen und es dann den Kubanern in die Schuhe zu schieben. Und das dann irgendwo rein zu fliegen. Das ist uraltes Ding, ist soweit man weiß nie umgesetzt worden, aber das ist ja immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen. Und da gab es dann eine TV-Serie namens Lone Gunmen. Das war so ein Spin-Off von X-Files, also die X-Akten. Und da haben sie das dann tatsächlich als Plot gehabt, dass ein ferngestörtes Flugzeug in das World Trade Center reinfliegt. Als Plot in dieser Show, bevor es tatsächlich passiert ist. Und das war dann auch nur so am Rande Teil des Narrativs, bis es wirklich dann Teil der Realität wurde. Aber es ist so ganz witzig zu sehen, dass es halt, was es dafür Abstufungen gibt als Teil des Narrativs.
Und wie lange die dann wieder reflektiert werden. Also wenn man zum Beispiel an diese Sherlock-Folge denkt, wo sie halt so ein Flugzeug voller Leichen haben, um halt irgendwie in irgendeiner Aktion durchzuziehen. Also dieses Flugzeug halt zu sprengen, um halt ihre Quelle nicht zu verbrennen. So das ist halt wieder auch so eine...
Ja super, das ist ganz großartige Geschichte.
Die mediale Reflektion davon so.
Ja, es braucht über ein paar Jahre, bis es so ein bisschen verdaut ist. Aber irgendwann wächst eben auch eine Generation auf, die das schon von Geburt an kennt und es auch überhaupt nicht in Frage steckt. Ja und das ist...
Also zum Beispiel das nächste Ding war natürlich mit dem Irak-Krieg. Wo der Major Consens Narrative, der uns in den Medien reingehämmert wurde, war, wir gehen da halt wegen den Massenvernichtungsmittel rein.
Na der erste Irak-Krieg, da haben wir ja noch humanitäre Gründe gehabt, weil die fiesen Iraker die armen Kuwaitis angegriffen haben.
Stimmt, genau diese Inkubator-Geschichte.
Und da gab es diese Inkubator-Geschichte. Wie war die denn? Also da gab es irgendwann im Fernsehen eine Zeugin, die ausgesagt hat, sie habe gesehen, eine Kuwaiti-Frau, relativ jung, die hat halt erzählt, tränenden Auges, sie habe gesehen, wie irakische Soldaten in Kuwait in die Krankenhäuser gegangen seien, hätten da die Babys aus den Inkubatoren gezogen, die Babys dann zum Sterben da liegen lassen und die Inkubatoren geklaut. Und Jahre später ist dann rausgekommen, dass die keineswegs eine Zeugin war, sondern Tochter des kubaitischen Botschaftes in den USA. Das war von vorne bis hinten erlogen.
Das war halt irgendwie so einer der krasseren Falle von Spindocktoring.
Ja, also einfach Narrativ.
Nicht mal Spindocktoring, sondern halt eben das sich eine Narrativ bauen, der komplett frei erfunden hat. Genau so frei erfunden war ja offensichtlich dann halt diese Massenvernichtungsmittel-Geschichte.
Naja, nicht ganz. Da gab es ja tatsächlich einen Präzedenzfall in den 80er Jahren, als der Rumsfeld den Irakis Waffenvernichtungswaffen verkauft hat.
Stimmt, ja, genau.
Aber diese teilt inzwischen expired. Es waren irgendwelche Biowaffen und das hält sich nicht beliebig lange.
Ja, aber da hat man trotzdem dieses Kippen genau gesehen. Also das ist halt einfach der Major Consistency-Narrative, die bösen Iraker haben, halt irgendwie Massenvernichtungswaffen. Deswegen müssen wir da hingehen, weil sonst schenken die die Al-Qaeda. So, und das ist halt irgendwie, wenn man so aus deutiger Perspektive dazu hört, denkt man so, hä? Wie konnte das jemand so glauben?
Aber das Lustige ist eben, dass die meisten dieser Sachen durch die Medien kommen und dass es eine Vereinsamung gibt, die durch das Internet inzwischen so ein bisschen kuriert wird, aber dass die Leute alle, wenn sie vor ihrer Glotze sitzen, auch sich so eine Sachen einreden lassen, weil sie nicht mitkriegen, ob es noch andere Leute gibt. Ja, also wir haben ja am Anfang erklärt, ob was die Wahrheit ist oder nicht, hängt im Wesentlichen davon ab, ob viele Leute glauben oder nicht, ob es die Mehrheit der Peer-Group glaubt, aber wenn man die Leute alle vereinsamt und die nur noch in ihren Häusern sitzen und dem Fernseher glauben, dann ist die Peer-Group, die sie wahrnehmen, auch was der Fernseher ihnen sagt. Das heißt, es ist einfacher, die Leute zu manipulieren, wenn sie halt nur den TV-Futzy haben und wenn alle die selben Nachrichten sehen. Und keiner quasi das als Erster ausspricht, dass er das eigentlich für unglaubwürdig hält, weil ja alle die selben Nachrichten sehen. Das Einzige, was gegen sowas hilft, ist eben, wenn man tatsächlich eine Peer-Group hat und mit ihnen redet. Und das schafft das Internet gerade so ein bisschen dabei. Wenn man es auch dafür nutzt.
Weil diese einseitige Konsensrealität der Tagesschau durchbrochen wird. So sieht das aus. Also diese irakische Massenvernichtungswaffengeschichte ist halt insofern auch interessant, weil es halt so eine selbstverstärkende Nummer waren. Also wo dann die Geheimdienste den Wunsch der Politiker in eine offizielle Wahrheit umgesetzt haben. Und sich dabei natürlich auch gewaltig die Finger und die Glaubwürdigkeit verbrannt haben. Und dann aber diese Selbstrepetierung, dass sie halt einfach eine Quelle hatten, die ihnen genau erzählt hat, was sie hören wollten. Diese Quelle wiederum benutzt haben, um die nächstgrößte Story zu drehen, die dann von den anderen, da gab's diese Curveball-Geschichte.
Curveball, so hieß die schlechte Quelle.
So hieß die schlechte Quelle. Und die alle anderen Dienste halt nicht haben wollten, weil da irgendwie zu Fischi war. Der BND hat ihn genommen, hat dann daraus Reports gemacht. Diese Reports gingen dann wiederum an die Amis. Und die Amis, die Amidienste haben gesagt, naja, den kennen wir, der ist nicht so richtig der Hit. Und trotzdem...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Andersrum, der BND hat an den Reports angeschrieben, hier ist der Report, aber wir halten den Typ für nicht vertrauenswürdig. Und die Amidienste haben gesagt, wir auch nicht, aber die Bush-PR-Leute haben gesagt, scheiß drauf, nehmen wir trotzdem.
Die Bush-PR-Leute haben dann den Colin Powell halt in die UNO geschickt dann, ne?
Der Brüller war das der Typ, der vor einem Jahr oder so ein Interview gegeben hat, wo er gesagt hat, ja, natürlich war das alles gelogen, aber ich war halt hier und dachte mir, dass jetzt deine Gelegenheit ist, ins Adam zu kippen. Super, so läuft es halt. Also es gibt hier in den US-Beschreibungen zu diesen Phänomenen gibt es einen Begriff, den ich ganz schön finde, nämlich Echo-Kammer. Wenn du einfach so einen Raum hast, wo immer dieselbe Scheiße von allen Wänden zurückreflektiert auf dich, dann hast du eben den Eindruck, du hast eine Peer-Group, die alle das Global denken, aber eigentlich ist es immer nur dieselbe Quelle und es reflektiert man nur von allen anderen. Das finde ich eigentlich so ein schönes Gedankenmodell, dass man gucken muss, dass man nicht nur in so einer Echo-Kammer sitzt, sondern mit Leuten redet.
Ja und eben auch mal guckt, was die Gegenseite so sagt oder Leute, die halt einfach nicht an die eigene Konsensrealität glauben und einfach mal versuchen, deren Gedanken Spiele oder deren Gedankenwelt nachzuvollziehen und so ein bisschen aus seinem eigenen Realitätstunnel rauszugucken, ist ja immer sehr hilfreich, weil man dann doch häufiger mal sieht, entweder, dass die halt sich in einem völlig abstrusen Realitätstunnel bewegen oder man selber möglicherweise irgendwo falsch abgebogen ist.
Also das Lustige ist ja bei diesen ganzen Verschwörungstheorien, wo immer die Geheimdienste irgendwas tun, dass man denen ja eigentlich so ins Geheimen alles zutraut, aber dann doch schockiert ist, wenn sie es tun. Also wir haben ja hier schon diese Drogenexperimente genannt, die es gab auch Geheimdienstunterwanderung von menschenrechtsorganisationen, zum Beispiel damals ebenso Martin Luther King und die Gleichberechtigungsbewegung für das COINTELPRO-Programm. Das war das COINTELPRO-Programm und Vietnamkriegsgegner, gut bei den Vietnamkriegsgegnern kann man so ein bisschen sogar noch verstehen, dass die Regierung irgendwie möglicherweise ein Interesse daran hat, die zu unterwandern. Aber wieso die die menschenrechtsorganisationen unterwandert haben, das ist ja bis heute nicht klar, was das sollte. Es gab so eine Hysterie damals von wegen...
Und die Kommunisten?
Dass die Kommunisten... Ja, aber das war doch eigentlich vorgeschoben, oder war das wirklich...
Naja, es war halt ein Weg halt zu versuchen, soziale oder nationale Kohärenz zu erhalten, indem man halt einen externen Feind, der dann plötzlich auch eine fünfte Kolonne im Inland hatte, produziert hat. Und es war halt durchaus ein... Ja, auch ein Produkt der leicht paranoigen Gedanken von J. Edgar Hoover.
Ja, da warst du ja allein auf dem gewissen...
Hast du den Film schon gesehen, J. Edgar?
Jaja, der Film ist auch großartig, ja.
Also vor allen Dingen interessant daran ist halt, J. Edgar Hoover war halt selber schwul und hatte einen Lover, der halt sein Sekretär war und das ist bis heute ein völliges Tabu in den USA. Also dass halt dieser Film, der lustigerweise von Clint Eastwood dirigiert wurde, das dann halt so andeutet und so ein bisschen zeigt, sorgt halt dafür so einen fetten Skandal und so. Die haben sich da richtig aufgeregt und angefangen zu klagen, glaube ich, oder gedroht zu klagen, weil J. Edgar Hoover eben der sozusagen das Idol des Law and Order Mannes und irgendwie das homophoben Grundkonsensus war, der da herrschte. Und dass der jetzt halt schwul sein und paranoid sein sollte, ging nun so gar nicht irgendwie, bis heute nicht.
Ja, der ist so die Wyatt Earp-Figur. Der Mann, der uns, der hat auch das FBI überhaupt erst eingeführt. Diese Idee, dass wir hier mal konzentriert was gegen tun müssen, weil wir so viele Feinde haben, die uns alle böses wollen. Der Mann war hochparanoid. Und dass das vielleicht nicht alles auf der Realität basiert hat, ist eine Sache, die viele Leute nicht hören wollen. Besonders die alte Generation natürlich, die dabei war. Weil sich daraus wieder so ein moralischer Druck ergibt. Wieso haben wir eigentlich nichts getan? Also das ist immer so eine Schwelle, die erst überwunden werden muss. Und viele von diesen Verschwörungstheorien sind auch erst dann akzeptiert, wenn die neueste Generation damit aufgewachsen ist. Ich kenn eigentlich so ein Spiel, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer den gesagt hat, aber es gibt das auch als Spruch, der in der Wissenschaft so, dass die Quantentheorie und solche Sachen setzen sich halt nicht durch, weil die Alten überzeugt werden, sondern weil die wegsterben. Und weil die neue Generation damit aufwächst, dass es die Wahrheit ist. Ja, so ist es natürlich auch in anderen sozialen Geschichten so, dass es gibt halt immer noch irgendwelche alten Leute, die in ihrer Gedankenwelt verhaftet sind, aber es wachsen eben neue nach und die kennen es dann eben als die Wahrheit. Und so kann sich auch ein Narrativ ändern, aber es ist natürlich eine sehr langfristige Sache. Na ja, wir haben hier noch mehr Beispiele für üble Geheimdienstsachen. Also es gibt ja seit vielen Jahren die Theorie, dass die Dienste irgendwelche fetten Datenbanken über uns alle führen. Irgendwann kamen dann, gab es dann Dokumente, dass es tatsächlich so eine Datenbank gibt und die heißt Main Core. Na ja, was da jetzt genau drin steht, ist natürlich immer noch geheim. Aber häufig gibt es ja auch keine komplette Aufklärung dann, sondern es gibt nur so Bits und Pieces und die reichen dann aber, um für den Einzelnen diese Schranke zu überwinden. Kann ich das jetzt insgesamt für glaubhaftig halten oder nicht? Das heißt, man muss ja auch gar nicht komplett Beweise für alle Details haben, sondern häufig reicht es schon. Man denkt sich, na ja, auch so eine Datenbank, das könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, aber die Geschichte kann ich noch nicht erzählen. Aber wenn dann der Name rauskommt von der Datenbank, dann reicht es eigentlich schon, um auch den Rest behaupten zu können. Also üblicherweise braucht man an Beweisen eben auch gar nicht komplett irgendwie Aufklärung, um am Narrativ erweitern teilzunehmen, sondern es reicht, wenn man so kleine Fetzen hat. Und auf denen kann man dann zeigen. Manchmal wird es auch richtig schlimm, wenn man dann später anfängt, Sachen aufzuklären, wird es schlimmer, als die Theorie vorher war. Also diese Iran-Contra-Geschichte und dass die CIA an dem Drogenverkauf teilnimmt, um damit ihre schwarzen Sachen zu finanzieren, das war völlig far out, als es damals auskam.
Drogen- und Waffenhandel durch die CIA war so eine Sache, die...
Das wollte keiner glauben.
Nein, das war halt dieser Oliver-Norse-Skandal. Da waren die Amerikaner auch tatsächlich richtig geschockt, als es sich so langsam rauskristallisiert hat. Das ist halt irgendwie tatsächlich der Fall war. Und da gab es dann so eine lustige Gegenreaktion bei diesen ultra-patriotisch konservativen Amerikanern. Für die ist Oliver-Norse ja immer noch ein Held. Und zwar deswegen, weil er das Notwendige getan hat. Das war ja nötig, um halt dem Kommunismus die Einheit zu gebieten. Und der Kongress wollte ja irgendwie das Geld dafür nicht raustun. Also hat er getan, was getan werden musste. Und ja, also sozusagen die moralische Verfehlung, halt Waffen und Drogen zu handeln als Geheimdienst, war dem gegenüber halt eine lästliche Sünde. Das finde ich auch interessant, dass dann so ein Übersprung von wir glauben es nicht zu, es war notwendig und deswegen richtig, dass wir es getan haben, gab.
Naja, es gibt ja auch so eine Idee, so das will ich eigentlich gar nicht wissen. Ja, also viele Leute gehen ja mit Geheimdiensten und auch der Polizei so um wie, naja, die müssen halt manchmal Dinge tun und ich will da eigentlich gar nicht darüber informiert werden. Denn wenn ich informiert werde, dann bin ich vielleicht nicht damit einverstanden.
Dann müsste ich auch vielleicht was tun, ja.
Genau, aber ich glaube ihnen vorausblickend, so dass sie eigentlich nur Dinge tun, die notwendig sind. Also notwendig ist ja auch eine sehr, ist ja genau wie Alternativlos, wonach wir hier unseren Podcast benannt haben. Das ist ja dasselbe Muster. Ja, dass man halt, das ist so die schwächste Art von Begründung, die man haben kann. Wenn man moralisch überhaupt nicht vertreten kann, dass irgendwas getan wird, dann sagt man, na ja, es ging nicht anders. Genau. Naja. Ja, Iran-Contra.
Ja.
Was haben wir hier noch? Sagen wir Pearl Harbor. Überlasse ich mal dir.
Ja, gut, die Pearl Harbor ist halt so interessant daran, dass es immer wieder Geschichten darüber gibt, wie ein historisches Ereignis abgelaufen ist, die halt von der offiziellen Geschichtsschreibung signifikant abweichen. Und die offizielle Geschichtsschreibung zu Pearl Harbor ist ja, die Amerikaner wurden überfallen, sie wussten vorhin nichts davon und sie hatten halt irgendwie keine Möglichkeit, sich zu wehren.
Was ja eigentlich auch so ein Mem ist schon bei den Amis, das gibt es ja bei fast jedem Krieg, erzählen sie einem nachher, sie sind hinterüchs angerufen worden und damit konnte niemand rechnen. Auch beim Vietnamkrieg gab es ja den Golf von Tonkin, das war ja auch so ein Ding, sie sind da zufällig durch die Gegend geschippert und haben nichts gerechnet und wurden da böse angeschossen von den fiesen Vietnamesen.
Ja, was halt auch sich am Ende als irgendwie inszenierter Unsinn herausstellte. Und die Geschichte, die ich mittlerweile habe, ist halt, dass es da persistente Gerüchte, Hinweise, Historiker gibt, die sagen, okay, die Amis hatten eigentlich davon schon gewusst, also es gab halt irgendwie da so Decrypts, die halt irgendwie liegen geblieben waren und irgendwie nicht rechtzeitig ankamen. Und wo halt sich die Historiker, das kommt uns ja auch bekannt vor aus der jüngeren Geschichte, könnte man möglicherweise da auch eine Parallele ziehen, dass Decrypts irgendwie zwar da waren, aber nicht rechtzeitig ankamen. Aber was dann tatsächlich passiert ist und wer wirklich zu welchem Zeitpunkt davon genau wusste, also was wirklich passiert ist, ist im Zweifel dann halt eben nicht mehr aufzuklären. Obwohl ich ja so diese 15 Jahre Regel habe. Es ist so, dass sich langsam rausstellt, dass so nach 15 Jahren etwa oder manchmal auch 30 Jahren, je nachdem, kommen dann so Sachen raus über bestimmte Eingüsse, die ja, die halt vorher niemand erzählen wollte. Oder weil die Leute dann halt einfach anfangen alt zu werden und irgendwie nochmal ihr Gewissen erleichtern, bevor sie ins Grab gehen. Oder weil bestimmte Loyalitätsstrukturen halt eben nicht mehr so vorhanden sind. Also wir beobachten zum Beispiel gerade bei dieser Geschichte um Tron. Ihr erinnert euch dunkel, der Hacker, der da in Berlin selbstmordet wurde und der sich halt irgendwie mit einem großen PayTV-Konzern offensichtlich angelegt hatte. Und da bröselt es jetzt gerade, weil eben diese Firma halt verkauft wird und plötzlich die Loyalitäten der Angestellten halt eben nicht mehr so richtig vorhanden sind. Und jetzt plötzlich die E-Mail-Konglomerate liegen und so. Und wir möglicherweise eben doch noch eine Chance haben eben dann jetzt so grob 15 Jahre später halt möglicherweise doch noch die Wahrheit zu erfahren, was da eigentlich passiert ist.
Das ist auch eine schöne Lektion in Sachen Narrativ, diese ganze Pay-TV-Geschichte, weil eine der Geschichten, die damals nicht erzählbar waren, war, dass der eine Pay-TV-Konzern Hacker bezahlt, um die Systeme von den anderen zu brechen, um sich einen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil zu verschaffen. Und das ist so ein, das wollte eigentlich keiner wissen und das wollte auch keiner glauben, wie das würden die da nicht machen, das ist doch zu hohes Risiko und so. Aber inzwischen verändert sich das so ein bisschen, das liest man jetzt gelegentlich an der Seite.
Mittlerweile sind halt die E-Mails geleakt, in denen genau steht, dass genau das passiert ist.
Ja, also da hat sich auch das Narrativ deutlich geändert. Ein Teil von diesen Fristen kommt auch daher, dass irgendwann die Geheimhaltung abläuft. Also gerade die Amerikaner sind da ja, haben da ja feste Fristen. Und da ist jetzt so die Zeit, wo diese ganzen Pearl Harbor Sachen eigentlich aufgedeckt werden müssen.
Ja, bestimmte Sachen werden halt auch für immer auf Geheim erklärt. Also es gibt ja immer noch Akten aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, die immer noch geheim sind. Weil eben sie im Zweifel halt den Geschichtsschreibungen narrativ angreifen würden. Und das will man dann halt auch nicht, eben aus übergeordneten Gründen der Narrativ-Raison.
Tja, das ist ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen, es gibt da noch so ein paar Metageschichten, wo nicht klar ist, ist das jetzt Ablenkung oder ist das wirklich eine Geschichte? Also so zum Beispiel diese Bilderberg-Treffen. Oder es gibt so ein Äquivalent dazu in Amerika, das ist der Bohemian Grove, das ist irgendwie so eine, naja, was ist das eigentlich, so ein Park, wo die sich dann treffen. Die Reichen und Mächtigen treffen sich in einer Geheimloge. Diese ganze geheimlogen Sache, ich bin mir da immer nicht sicher, ob das wirklich eine Geschichte ist oder ob das eher eine Ablenkung ist, weil das ist so ein schönes Ding, was du rumwedeln kannst, um Aufmerksamkeit zu binden, wo es dann plötzlich gar nicht mehr geht, warum die sich treffen und was die da möglicherweise besprechen, sondern nur dass die sich treffen. Und dann bildet sich so eine Fangemeinde von Leuten, die da rumstalken und die irgendwie Handyvideos verwackelt drehen von irgendwelchen Bäumen. Und also, ich bin mir da immer nicht sicher. Aber naja, es ist schon ein valider Teil des Narrativs darüber zu reden, wie eigentlich dieses Unter-Meinungsfindung in den Eliten funktioniert. Und da ist es schon so eine Sache. Die Bilderberger sind ja auch lange Zeit ein Gerücht gewesen, dass sie sich überhaupt treffen.
Beziehungsweise wurde es halt hingestellt als so ein, ja, also da gibt es...
Ach naja, wir haben halt Urlaub gemacht.
Genau, wir haben halt zusammen Urlaub gemacht, ein bisschen Golf gespielt oder so. Und so nach und nach stellt sich dann eben draus, nachdem jetzt irgendwie Einleitungslisten rausliegen und so, dass da tatsächlich irgendwie eine Menge interessanter Leute sich treffen. Und eben dadurch, dass sie so geheimnisgremerisch darüber sind, was sie da eigentlich tun, natürlich irgendwie noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit generieren und noch mehr Interesse erzeugen. Nun kann man sich natürlich eben tatsächlich fragen, ob es sich um ein Ablenkungsmanöver handelt, wo, ja, die da alle sich mal treffen, um halt irgendwie alle Verschwörungsfreaks dieses Planeten irgendwie einmal in die Irre zu schicken oder ob sie tatsächlich die Gelegenheit benutzen, um da irgendwie die neue Weltregierung zu besprechen. Kann man nicht wissen, bis mal wieder irgendjemand eine Aufzeichnung von den Treffen da liegt. Vielleicht passiert das ja auch mal irgendwann.
So meinst du, wie bei der Wannsee-Konferenz, ja? Viele Jahre später taucht dann ein Protokoll auf.
Ja, genau. So was, ja.
Das wäre natürlich schon cool, ja.
Naja, also da gibt's, also solche Geschichten gibt's ja irgendwie reihenweise, also gerade mit den Geheimdiensten. Interessant ist aber eigentlich dabei dann, wie solche, also wie man unterscheidet man solche Geschichten, die hinter sich als wahr herausstellen oder als tatsächlich das, was passiert ist, von völligen Bullshit-Geschichten. Na also wie macht man das? Und ein guter Indikator dafür, dass es Bullshit ist, ist, wenn es eine offizielle Ansage ist. Also wenn halt irgendwie es eine offizielle Aussage, dass es so oder so gibt, dann kann man eigentlich mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit davon ausgehen, dass es sich dabei irgendwie um entweder eine Cover-Story handelt, also oder eine Erdachte-Geschichte oder einen kompletten Bullshit, der halt irgendwie fabriziert wird, um irgendeine Geheimdienstoperation zu decken. Und so, also die, diese, was war diese Geschichte, diese Gloma Explorer, wie hieß das?
Ja, das war, da ging es um ein U-Boot der Russen, was irgendwo, haben wir auch schon mal eine Sendung zu gehabt.
Die hatten wir mit Compa, hatten wir die, ne?
Markus Compa, ne, ja, genau. Ja, also, wenn es offizielle Ansagen zu Sachen gibt, wo es vorher Verschwörungstheorien zu gibt, dann glaubt die einfach generell keiner. Das ist auch ein Muster, was ihnen dann schmerzt, wenn es wirklich nichts gab. Ja, ich sag jetzt mal irgendwie Alien Hysterie. Da haben sie dann auch versucht, das zu...
Ja, bloß, ich meine, bei der, also Alien Hysterie ist dann ein schönes Beispiel dafür, welchen Aufwand man teilweise treibt, gerade bei wirklich geheimen Projekten, um so eine Bullshit-Story zu platzieren. Also der größte Teil der Alien-Geschichten, so um Area 51, war ja offensichtlich halt fabrizierter Unsinn, um die Tests von Stealth-Flugzeugen und Hochgeschwindigkeitsflugzeugen da zu taren. Und bis hin dazu, also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel diese Geschichten von den Skunkworks liest, also sozusagen den wirklich geheimen Teil der amerikanischen Rüstungsfertigung, dass die teilweise irgendwie bis zum Viertel des gesamten Projektbudgets dafür ausgeben, um plausible Coverstories zu begründen. Also bis hin dazu, dass die...
Mehr oder weniger plausibel gelegentlich haben sie es schon mal so richtig toll verkackt.
Ja klar, aber häufiger mal haben sie es halt auch eben nicht verkackt. Also zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit dem, mit dieser Drohne, die da im Iran eingefangen wurde. Wenn man sich die Geschichte mal anguckt, das ist echt spannend. Die haben diese Drohne geflogen, die hieß damals noch Darkstar. Und dann ist sie in eine abgeschmiert. Also ist halt abgestürzt. Und daraufhin hat der Kongress das Funding für dieses Programm gecancelt. Also die gab es dann halt nicht mehr. Hat sich offenbar nicht bewährt, war viel zu teuer, irgendwie alles scheiße. Dann gab es irgendwie lange Artikel in den Aviation-Magazinen und in den Geheimdienst- und Militärzeitungen, wo drin stand, warum es alles scheiße ist und irgendwie diese Drohne nie was werden wird. Aber was tatsächlich passiert war, ist, dass sie das Programm einfach nach Ultra Dark bewegt haben und gesagt haben, hier macht mal weiter, hier ist Geld und wir reden halt nicht mehr drüber.
Das heißt jetzt anders.
Heißt jetzt anders. Bis dann halt irgendwie dann irgendwann die ersten Bilder von diesem so genannten Biest von Kandahar herauskamen, also dieser Drohne, die sie dann halt im Iran eingefangen haben. Und so eine Geschichten zeigen eben wieder ganz klar, wenn es dann zu einer offiziellen Verlautbarung zu gibt, gerade bei so etwas Mysteriösen und so ein bisschen ein bisschen nackwürdigen Geschichten, dann kann man eigentlich einigermaßen fest davon ausgehen, dass es sich um Bullshit handelt.
Auch andersrum, aber das ist natürlich immer schwieriger zu sagen, aber so als, um mal nur so auf den Tisch zu legen, was es alles an Sachen gab, die mal irgendwie nur Verschwörungstiere waren, dass es die NSA gibt, war lange Zeit nicht gesichert. Dass es einen Mossad gibt, war lange Zeit nicht gesichert. Dass es israelische Atombocken gibt, hätten ja am liebsten immer noch, dass das ungesichert gilt. Also das sind schon auch durchaus wirklich wichtige Sachen, nicht nur so irgendwie Spinnerkram.
Oder zum Beispiel die Geheimgefängnisse, das ist ja eh nach 9-11.
Und ja, genau.
Das war ja lange Zeit eine Verschwörungstheorie, wo alle, auch deutsche Politiker, sagten, nee, das kann ja nicht sein, das würden die doch niemals tun.
Und nicht die Amerikaner, das sind unsere Freunde.
Genau. Und die wussten aber zu dem Zeitpunkt natürlich schon, dass es so was gibt. Und dann erst nach und nach sickerte das dann raus. Und in einigen der Länder, wo diese Foltergefängnisse waren oder sind, wird es ja bis heute nicht zugegeben. Also dass die Staatsräson hat nicht stattgefunden. Und da werden Medienberichte zensiert, die darüber berichten.
Na klar. Sollten wir ja genauso machen, wie die Regierung wäre. El Fefe und Frank Rieger.
Du würdest es tun. Ich bin ja der Revolutionär hier.
Du wärst ja danach mein Innenminister. Du wärst ja genau zuständig. Ich muss dich ja von der Straße kriegen, sonst kann ich da nie in Ruhe durchgehen.
Ich bin im Exil. Aber warte, eines Tages komme ich wieder, um dich zu stürzen.
Tja, aber ein lustiges Detail ist auch, dass das genau die Gegenstrategie für Verschwörungstheorien ist. Dass man andere Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet, die eben unglaubwürdiger sind. Und versucht, mit Assoziationen die eigentliche Theorie, die man angreifen will, vom Markt zu holen. Ja, also das kann entweder funktionieren, indem man wirklich unglaubwürdigen Bullshit erzählt. Also als Beispiel will ich immer die Camp Trails nennen. Das ist so eine Sache, das bindet einen gut Teil der Verschwörungsbranche. Im Internet beschäftigen sich mit irgendwelchen Flugzeugausdünstungen und da gibt es mit Sicherheit genug von. Aber das ist nicht irgendwie die Idee, dass die Regierung uns über Flugzeugausdünstungen vergiften will.
Unsere Gedanken kontrolliert?
Unsere Gedanken kontrolliert, genau. Dann diese Echsenmenschen-Geschichte. Da müsst ihr mal ein bisschen rum googeln. Da gibt es dann so Fotoshops, wie irgendwie wo bei der Queen so ein bisschen Echsenhaut durchschiebert. Und dann denkst du, unfassbar, was da für eine Energie gebunden wird. Aber eine andere Methode, die also noch besser funktioniert, aus meiner Sicht, ist, wenn man so Widerlichkeiten untermischt. Also wenn man zu einer an sich validen Theorie noch so einen rassistischen oder antisemitischen oder so einen Anti-Freimaurer-Bullshit dazu erzählt. Um das gesamte Narrativ in so eine Ecke zu dringen, dass man eigentlich, um die Schwelle zu erhöhen, die Leute überwinden müssen, um dem zu glauben. Weil sie sagen, nee, also der Aspekt ist ja offensichtlich, das geht gar nicht. Und das ist eine valide Gegenstrategie gegen Verschwörungstheorien aus Regierungssicht. Dass man einfach versucht zu sagen, das sind keine Fußballfans, das sind Hooligans.
Also gegen Wahrheiten, dass man sie eben als Verschwörungstheorie...
Oder diese ganze Alien-Geschichte muss man ja auch aus dem Blickwinkel sehen. Dass die Regierung natürlich auch auf der einen Seite Ärger damit hatten, auf der anderen Seite war das eben aber auch wunderbar für die, dass sie ihre schönen Black Ops Geschichten, ihre Skunkworks Testflüge hinter dieser ganzen Alien-Scheiße verbergen konnten. Und Leute, die sich das tatsächlich angucken wollten, sahen alle wie irgendwelche Vollidioten aus. Crackpots aus der Alien-Szene. So macht man das als Regierung.
Ja, also, wenn wir mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen.
Bleibt eigentlich nur eine Sache zu sagen.
Genau. Es besteht keine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung.
Natürlich nicht.
Ja, gut, dann...
Das war's eigentlich schon. Wir sind schon wieder bei über eineinhalb Stunden auf Wire.
Oh ja. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Den Flatter-Button findet ihr gleich auf der Homepage. Wenn ihr Lust habt, da draufzuklicken, freuen wir uns natürlich. Wie immer. Wir hoffen, dass wir dann demnächst mal irgendwie das Sendungstempo wieder ein bisschen angezogen bekommen. Wenn Fefe wieder da ist.
Wenn wir das nicht mehr über das Internet machen müssen.
Ja, wir machen ja gerade mit so einem Super-Experimentellen-Setup mit parallelem Recording und dazwischen irgendwie Brucken-Worb-Telefonie und so. Ja, aber Fefe ist dann demnächst auch irgendwann wieder da und dann wird irgendwie alles gut.
Wir haben ein paar schöne Sendungen geplant. Bis dahin bleibt uns gewogen.
Genau. Und immer schön hingucken und schauen, welche Wahrheiten vielleicht auch hinterfragt werden sollten. Denn vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.